e
if everyone could start taking your
morning morning Mr chair good morning
how are you good I'm representative
Jerry Canon oh nice to meet you nice to
you morning Bill good morning how are
you good good how are you and we are
with the community the mental health 94
yeah I mean I'm not sure we'll be of
close we may be running
over okay if everyone could take please
take your seats I'd like to
begin we have a very full day and a lot
of great people here to present to us uh
I'd like to begin if uh hopefully
there's no objection uh if you'll join
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all thank
you sorry
you I'd like to welcome you all here my
name is Wayne McDonald I have the
privilege of being the chairman of this
committee for this term and um as as you
hopefully know um because you're here
this is the committee house committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs uh what I'd like to do to begin
this morning is just go around the table
uh quickly just introduce ourselves and
um where we're from what district what
county and so forth again my name is
Wayne McDonald I'm from londondary which
is Rockingham County District 16
representative Lon I am representative
Erica Leon Vice chairman of the
13 welcome Mr chairman ifp and I have
been friends
for I think probably 20 years long time
and that's how long I've been on this uh
committee uh I am the only person that
can say this this is my district right
here
representative I I'd like to point out
representative um McKay is also the
senior member of this committee longest
serving member of this committee
currently so um it's another distinction
he has in addition to being our Host
this
morning
representative my name is uh Leah
kushman I'm representative from where in
uh Hillsboro County District
28 hi I'm Jerry Canon I'm uh straford
District 12 uh that's uh summersworth
and
Rollinsford hello my name is Seth King
and I live in Whitefield and that is
4 good morning my name is Jim Murphy I'm
from Handover and lime representing
Grafton
12 Mark mlan Manchester uh Hillsboro
Bill Palmer from Cornish planfield and
representing Sullivan District
2 Yuri Po from Hook at mar mar
10 welcome representative
King representative Bill Kang from
Milford New Hampshire of course New
Hampshire and um Hillsboro County
District
43 good morning and welcome I'm Lucy
Weber uh I'm the ranking member of the
committee and I represent chesher five
which is Walpole and S cheser
County good morning my name is Gary
Merchant I represent Sullivan County
district 6 which is claron and Cen this
is my second term on this committee and
my third term in the
house hello I'm representative Lisa
merer from Hillsboro District 44 uh for
good
morning went off there you go thank you
very much good morning again I am Mary
fedus from Manchester New Hampshire
District Hillsboro District 26 and I'm
happy to be returning to this committee
I had taken a little Hiatus with the
election law committee but I'm glad to
be back time we serve together there too
you can't get rid of me no matter where
you go representative
yes hi I'm Dave Nagel I'm a rookie um
I'm from uh gilmington Guilford I
6 good morning I'm Fran Nutter upam um
NASA Ward six Hillsboro
8 okay welcome all and it's great to
have you here I look forward to working
with you this current term did did you
want me to um sure if you want go ahead
yeah so hi I'm uh Jess Edwards I'm the
chair of division 3 uh this is the
second term we've tried to do this
integrated orientation between division
3 which is the financing of uh the
department uh along with the policy
committee I think it recognizes that
there isn't a firewall between policy
and uh Financial results and so we we we
need to work together we need to talk to
one another we got a couple other
members of division 3 here as well so oh
and three others so uh I appreciate the
integration uh with this committee and
uh looking forward to a very productive
uh two years together okay same here
representative thank
you okay well thank you everybody now
we're actually a little bit ahead of
schedule I I wasn't sure how long that
would take but um um just a couple
housekeeping things uh represent the
schedule of bills did you already
distribute that or no um there not okay
yeah representative Leon and I have been
spending some time uh trying to lay out
a tentative schedule for the committee
right now we're looking at Wednesdays to
be um starting next Wednesday in fact
and obviously those bills will all be
noticed and um um you know going forward
we'll be working around house session
days and so forth I understand there
might be a day or two of house session
days on Wednesdays also did you want to
say something representative um if we're
looking at a schedule that will allow us
to meet one day a week for committee um
that will require us keeping questions
limited to the questions that we need to
know from people who are coming to
present to our committee um as opposed
to pontificating with an if I know
question by doing that it looks like we
can get through these in in a solid
pathway um we are looking to sort of
block them off the 9:00 group The 10:30
group and the 1:00 group so that if we
stay on track and um and if something
doesn't demand longer attention then
we'll be able to take a little break
before 10:30 and then have a good solid
lunch hour but it also will allow us
some time if we run into some unexpected
issues we won't be cut short and we
we'll make sure that we're giving every
bill it's due we are looking at doing
full days on Wednesdays from 9:00 a.
until probably 3:45 345 is opposed to
four because I know some people need to
leave early because of child care and
other family commitments um so that that
that's our goal anyway and and again you
know we'll see how how it works and we
may get to Bunch times when we may need
to revise that and of course everyone
will be you know appropriately
informed with that um I'd like to move
on to our first presenter uh Maggie
ca
yes oh okay thank you I made a I made a
circle and I blocked off part of the
letter so apologize for
that and if you can push the button so
it's red thank you how's
that I'm a quick learner um good morning
and thank you very much for having me
I'm a little outside the DHHS realm in
that I represent all the 10 Community
Mental Health Centers who do the major
work of mental health in New Hampshire
and have been in mental health and
Community Mental Health specifically for
the last 40 years of my life um
currently as the president I'm here to
do a little foreshadowing with you about
our cbha agenda for this year with the
legislature first and foremost we are
looking to close the wage gap between
our centers employees because of the
workforce crisis our wage Gap is
significant when you think about a
master's level clinician who works in a
Community Mental Health Center making
around $60,000 a year which is an
admirable salary but if you go to work
at the maram county jail as a social
worker you'll get 80 and a sign on bonus
that we can't afford and can't compete
with so we're we're stuck in a bad place
right now so that is our priority is to
close the wage Gap cbha is currently
meeting with the governor's budget and
policy team and legislative budget
writers to present the facts and explain
the critical need for this increase in
Medicaid rates
and the reason its Medicaid rates is
because Community Mental Health Centers
as the vendor with
DHHS primarily is funded by Medicaid
okay so most of the 10 centers between
60 and 85% of their budget is
Medicaid um we appreciated the efforts
Last by Anum um whereby we saw an
increase twice
3.1% um and we are here to say that we
need to bring our salaries up to the
level of other providers and that the
Medicaid underlying fee for Service
rates would need to increase to a huge
amount right a range of about 21.5 to
23% representing 26 to $28 million
shortfall in our wages we should be able
to agree that New Hampshire needs an
adequately funded mental health system
not a poorly resourced one because we
all know what's going on in the world
but there are successes that we have
accomplished in the last two years we've
added 60 additional beds um and we have
put up a rapid response team that many
of you I'm sure have heard advertised on
TV or radio whereby we are helping to
meet people in the community who are in
crisis and keep them out of the
emergency room so that we're not taking
up precious bed space and resources and
we're able to serve them in crises in
their home in their schools wherever
they are we also want to emphasize the
importance today of Medicaid expansion
which needs to be reauthorized this year
and is another legislative priority for
us data from the division of Medicaid
services from Henry and parties say that
990,000 New Hampshire residents have
expanded medicaid of those 11,000 of
them have mental health care and 30,000
of them use Medicaid services for
medication treatment of mental health
disorders and there are almost 9,000
additional people who take substance use
disordered
services our Workforce as I noted is a
problem across the health care spectrum
and you know this access to tella health
is important for us to improve and ease
the access as well as attract a
Workforce our support for housing both
for the workforce housing and our
patients lessening the administrative
burden and bureaucratic burdens as a
retention strategy as well in as Improv
in Access if a doctor is doing tons of
paperwork or a clinician is doing tons
of paperwork it's taking time away from
seeing the patients that they need to
see and when we have few of those people
around and available we want to make
sure that we are decreasing any
administrative burdens that we can we
are also interested in streamlining
licensing and certification requirements
for Recruitment and desirability of
working in New Hampshire continued
investments will be required for our
state loan repayment program which has
been very successful for us in terms of
recruiting people and keeping people but
we'd like to see it expanded to
bachelor's level
clinicians I'm happy to entertain any
questions and this is Susan pasel and
she is our lobbyist from the DuPont
group in case you don't know her thank
you and we the DuPont group represents
the community Behavioral Health
Association and by state Primary Care
Christine Stoddard is their lobbyist who
you'll be meeting um she's unable to be
here today but I have a letter in hand
out from her thank you thank you very
much any questions from committee
members yes I have two questions thank
you very much um I'm curious who do you
see as your competition in terms of
hiring so primarily
for-profit um health care providers that
are doing substance abuse work hospitals
no offense to the guys from over in
Lebanon area but you know when Mary when
Hitchcock hospital or Mary Hitchcock as
I used to call it um gets a $10,000
$20,000 bonus sign on and I'm offering
2,000 for a clinician or a nurse I just
can't compete so it's other health care
providers and if you will richer more
resourced Health Care
Providers um can I ask sure go ahead um
my other question had to do with tah
health I'm really curious about that
what this is going to be a difficult
question to answer I assume but what
percentage of your care do you see as
teleah health where do you see that
going in the FI future and what's the
reimbursement from that for you so
currently the reimbursement is the same
as if you were face to face right the
federal government did that with the ph
and it continues um in my neck of the
woods which would be your neck of the
woods um internet is not that available
and patients of ours who are on Medicaid
often can't afford internet access um
and so my business in Laconia is
probably only about 40% tah health I
would like to see it go up um because I
think that more people could take
advantage of it especially with limited
Transportation um it's easier for the
patients as well as the providers um but
I I'm hoping that that number increases
and that tella Health stays with us for
a long time because it has made a world
of difference to people especially
during Co thank you
questions thank you very much and
congratulations oh thank you very much
and thanks for being here this
morning um we're running really well
here smooth more smoothly and quicker
than I thought um Mr Williams did you do
you want to go at this point or is it
too early do you want to want to wait a
bit
or I I thought I'd be apologizing for us
running a little bit late and I'm
apologizing instead that we're running a
little early so and chairman McDonald uh
for the record or for the committee's
pleasure I'm John Williams I'm the
director of legislative affairs and the
department is always Nimble and flexible
and I see our commissioner and the
others are ready to go okay great full
disclosure I have the privilege of uh
being U an employee in the department
for 23 years I retired in June of 2019 I
was in the Fraud Unit so it's good to
see rip Mr Williams again he and I
worked on many cases together uh he's a
former prosecutor he was invaluable in
terms of search warrants and affidavits
and all kinds of legal stuff uh thank
you very much attorney Williams for of
your help during my time there and I'm
I'm delighted to be working with you
again as well as the other members of
the department and chairman McDonald
thank you very much for those very kind
words and you were an absolute
contributor to the department and I
reflect very fondly on our working
relationship in the past thank you thank
morning you're on time but I'm afraid
the department may make you off time off
schedule hopefully not well starting a
few minutes early hi good morning my
name is Lori Weaver I'm actually the
interim commissioner for heal human
services welcome and congratulations
also thank you I think great and Marissa
hen associate commissioner at dgj so in
in the interest of not clogging up the
table with chairs I have two other
associate Commissioners that will once
we speak will come up and and share as
well um but it's nice to see you all and
thank you for inviting us I remember
being here last year with commissioner
shanet and at that time I obviously was
a Deputy Commissioner uh for about two
and a half three years and be prior to
that I was an associate commissioner
I've been with the Department over 20
years about 25 in total doing business
with the department and been in human
services field for 30 plus years so I
feel I have a good sense of the of the
department although there's always more
to learn for sure so uh thank you for
having us here today and I'll let
Marissa introduce herself great so again
Marissa hen um I grew up here in conquer
um spent my career after college and
graduate school out of state in New York
and Utah primarily but upon starting my
own family wanted my daughter to have
the same um incredible childhood and
healthy childhood that I was fortunate
to have here so returned to the Granite
State about a year and a half ago um and
was privileged to accept the position of
associate commissioner um under uh under
Lori Weaver's leadership here um at the
department uh the areas we as associate
Commissioners we really work um cross-
departmentally looking for as many
opportunities for integration and um
strategic alignment as possible um but
that said we do have some particular
areas of focus and in my case um that is
uh DCF division for children youth and
families which of course is both child
welfare and Juvenile Justice as well as
the division for Behavioral Health um
which encompasses uh both the community-
based uh mental health system that we
just just heard about um as well as our
rapid response our um acute system the
last thing I'll just say as you're
probably aware um just over six months
ago uh the state acquired Hamstead
Hospital which has long been the sole
psychiatric hospital for children in our
state so that is now a state run
facility and I'm um very pleased with
not only how it's going but with the
opportunity to support that facility
under DHHS oversight um and uh and so
that is also part of my portfolio thank
you thank you and I just want to make
sure everybody has a copy of the long
list of folks that we've brought with us
today for our team um that will go
through as well as a contact information
that has all of the U roles and phone
numbers should you need to reach
anybody so with that I'll have uh Ann
Landry and Chris anello our two
you good morning
good Mo good morning is it on you have
the red button am I on now you are thank
you I can see the red button one of
these days I'll get it straight it's
just like Zoom meetings right um so I am
Chris sanello I am um another associate
commissioner here at the department um
like Marissa said we all have broad
areas of support of um where we oversee
and work within um primarily I oversee
the division of Economic and housing
stability which um is our elig ibility
programs our um Child Care homeless
Services child support all of those um
programs and our division of long-term
supports and services which is Youth and
adults um and children with disabilities
as well as seniors and Adult Protective
Services temporarily I also um provide
um support to the Bureau of Information
Services um I have been with the
department since
2016 I've been an associate commissioner
since
2021 prior to coming to the department I
led a nonprofit in The Lakes Region and
I still live in The Lakes Region so
you good morning thank you for having us
my name is Ann Landry I'm also one of
the three associate Commissioners I've
been with the department for about four
years um prior to which I've spent my
career between Maine and New Hampshire
and and Healthcare um as well I did my
graduate work here in New Hampshire and
then moved back to Maine and and worked
in the healthare system there and then
returned to be closer to my elderly
parents who I'm lucky enough to live in
the same town so good to be here
supporting the work um of all the
residents in New Hampshire I spend
primarily um my time is with the
division of Medicaid services and the
division of Public Health um which I'm
very fortunate to work with the
directors in those divisions um as well
as the office of Health Equity um and
program integrity and quality as well so
thank you so much for having us and I
look forward to getting to know you
you good morning chairman McDonald and
committee members my name is Jonathan
Ballard I work as the chief medical
officer for for the Department I've been
with the department for five years in
this role um although I uh had trained
in Family Medicine uh and public health
here in New Hampshire prior to this role
I worked as the state epidemiologist in
the state of Kentucky before returning
back to New Hampshire where my wife has
lots of roots and family and we have two
children live here in conquer um obv
obviously um it's been busy several
years with the clinical programs of the
department uh I provide medical
oversight for the clinical programs and
work with all areas of the department on
clinical programs um and uh quality
improvement of those medical programs
a resource to you if there's any
questions about any health care issues
medical issues uh related to legislation
this upcoming session you have my
you good morning committee good morning
chair McDonald good morning I am
Patricia Tilly I am the director of the
division of Public Health Services um
and thank you for the time that you've
uh carved out today as we talk about the
vast breath of the work here at the
department I've worked at the department
uh for more than 20 years I have served
as the director for just about almost
two years now I grew up here in coner I
live in New London my kids graduated
from the karge Regional School District
I have the privilege of spending a lot
of time here at the Legislative Office
building over the past 20 years um I've
spent a lot of time focused on issues
such as Women's Health Children's Health
peratal substance misuse Early Childhood
Services data governance but the
interests of my team and my
extraordinary team behind us go well
beyond those particular issues the
division of Public Health is unique
among DHHS divisions in that our job is
to protect promote and improve that
health and well-being of all residents
here in New Hampshire you and me and the
constituents that you serve we don't
have a particular clientele our efforts
improve and protect the health of
everyone there is not one person in the
state that is not touched by public
health policies from the safety of the
food that you eat to access to high
quality Health Care Services when you're
sick and to keep you well to consistent
and reliable data that tell tells us
about the trends in the health and
well-being of our neighbors and our
friends to ensuring that we're ready to
act when we're faced with emergencies as
diverse from a possible radiological
event at seabook or mobilizing more than
two million vaccines and vaccinations
during a global pandemic Public Health
has a budget of about 200 million with
approximately 73% of our funds coming
from the federal government and less
than 10% of our funds coming from the
general fund even though all of us got a
lesson in public health 101 over the
past few years we are often at our best
when you don't even know we're there we
have more than 400 staff in seven
bureaus um in public health and our
Bureau Chiefs are here with me today and
as I introduce them they're going to
sort of stand in wave so you get a sense
of of who they are so I'll start out
with Dr fun Shang gal he is the chief of
our public Public Health laboratory the
lab has phology chemistry microbiology
expertise and does everything from
making sure that the shellfish grown off
our Coast in New Hampshire waters are
safe to eat to making sure private
wellwater is safe and clean to drink and
testing for sexually transmitted
infections to the ongoing covid response
our laboratory now processes hundreds of
thousands of covid samples and stands
ready to serve
the public and the healthc Care
community in case of any emergency
whether it is another Global pandemic or
biot terrorism Ryan tannan is our neest
chief of the Bureau of infectious
diseases he is a pharmacist and he is an
active Lieutenant uh colonel in the
National Guard his leadership helped us
through the massive vaccination effort
for covid-19 and he is currently leading
the team through routine work in
everything from HIV to TB to Vector born
diseases such as lime disease waterborne
illnesses such as Legionella our team
manages complex Data Systems and
provides epidemiology on all infectious
diseases you'll hear from Ryan during
the session as we weigh in on bills
related to vaccines and infectious
diseases chawe Chala is our chief for
the Bureau of public health statistics
and informatics public health is
responsible for scores of complex Data
Systems and data sets chway Works
closely with Dave weeders and our
department of information Technologies
do it to ensure governance and data
stewardship protects confidential and
private data she oversees the analysis
of everything from cancer data from our
cancer registry to data on the youth
risk behavioral survey the y RBS and
ensures that our public platform called
the New Hampshire DHHS data portal
formerly known as wisdom provides
everyone in the state with credible
validated data and analyses about a
whole range of Health topics I hope that
you have the opportunity at some point
to get online Google New Hampshire data
portal and take a look at the wealth of
information that is available to
everyone at your fingertips you'll see
chowe over the session weigh in on bills
related to health conditions data
Registries and surveys such as the
yrbs Lisa soroy is our new chief for the
Bureau of population health and
Community Services as formally as the
New Hampshire Wick director Lisa is well
known to many of you and to many
committees for her work in supporting
nutrition services for pregnant women
children and Elders in our community and
her her advocacy around breastfeeding
supports population Health seeks to
ensure Equitable access to um all health
care services for all people in the
state most importantly this team
supports Community Systems that assist
vulnerable adults and children to have
the resources they need for healthy
outcomes that's everything from our
federally qualified Health Centers to
our Wick programs to Our Family Resource
Center ERS and as we transition out of
the acute phase of covid and with the
public health emergency ending which
you're going to hear a lot more about
from my colleagues behind me we know
that we are going to need to make sure
that families do not fall in between the
cracks as the chief of population Health
you will see her and her team here as we
focus on a wide range of women's health
issues infant and child Wellness chronic
disease tobacco use we anticipate lots
of Interest this year in issues such as
maternal mortality and access to Labor
and Delivery Systems across the state
Michelle Roberge is our chief of the
Bureau of Public Health protection
Public Health protection is the home of
many of our uh regulatory functions in
public health and efforts to promote
environmental health everything from
food protection lead poisoning
prevention to environmental Public
Health
tracking environmental Public Health
tracking brings together both
environmental and public health data in
one place to help inform our Public
Health action Michelle and her team have
been deeply engaged in many of the
commissions addressing environmental
health exposures chronic diseases and
cancer
we anticipate there will be some bills
coming from these commissions this year
and we will be there to weigh in on the
that those bills Stephanie lock is our
chief of emergency preparedness response
and Recovery uh we call that eeper it's
fun name and it takes the lead in all of
our emergency planning and executions in
times of a public health emergency Steph
and her team were some of the
professional that leveraged Partnerships
with the rest of the department uh the
department of safety's Homeland Security
and Leadership straight to the
governor's office throughout the
covid-19 response her team not only
helped arrange the administration of
millions of covid-19 vaccines to
individuals who were voluntarily seeking
that protection for themselves and their
families her team also managed the
distribution of millions of pieces of
PPE um antigen tests ventilators to our
healthc care pro providers our schools
and our community organizations if there
is an emergency you want Steph on your
team so I'm just letting you all know
that's the woman that is who we want if
there is an emergency Steph team Steph's
team also coordinates our regional
public health networks ensuring they
have the resources they need to provide
supports within the communities that you
serve we currently have a vacancy for
our bureau chief for public health
policy access and Equity so if you know
someone send them our way um that team
however is continuing to provide the
same level of services and systems and
support for everything from our
prescription drug monitoring program
that program used to sit over in a
different part of the state government
over um in oplc it currently resides as
of last bium or this current bium within
the division of Public Health
Services um it also that this Bureau
also has our therapeutic cannabis
program and we also provide support for
Rural health and Primary Care the
therapeutic cannabis program currently
serves over 13,000 individuals um there
are always bills of Interest many of
which are heard in this committee Mike
HT who is not here with us today is well
known throughout this building for his
expertise in all things cannabis policy
and I have no doubt that you will see
him again over the course of the session
there are some small technical tweaks
that we want to make to the prescription
drug monitoring program this year to
assist with data collection and
Reporting and so you will hear more
about that later this year and there are
often many healthc care Workforce
initiatives and Rural Health
considerations that we will weigh in on
as well
one of the most familiar faces that you
will see from public health is Abby
Rogers who is with us and she is our
Public Health legislative liaison she'll
be here monitoring bills providing
testimony and most importantly providing
resources and information when any of
you have a public health related
question she is a wealth of information
if she doesn't know the answer she'll
seek out the experts who do and you'll
have an email back in your inbox within
the day or shorter
other folks who have not been able to
join us today are our state
epidemiologist Dr Ben Shan he is the
most TV famous of all of us here in
public health he typically does not
spend so much time here in the policy
sphere or the Legislative Office
Building he focuses most of his time on
infectious disease investigation and
epidemiology but he will provide his
expertise whenever needed we're also
missing today our division uh d director
Ian watt who is currently home with a
brand new baby his work however focuses
much on the operation internal Workforce
and administration of the division he
helps make sure that all the trains are
running on time and we hit all of our
deliverables and we have a Workforce
that is ready to serve the people of the
state last year there were more than 200
bills that had something to do with
public health of those bills public
health staff were engaged in 45 bills
while all of those bills were not
necessarily in HHS Anda many of them
were heard in this committee or
certainly were of interest to this
committee similarly this year you will
see and hear from our staff at many of
your hearings in on topics as diverse as
data privacy reproductive health
environmental health and
immunization some of the things that are
at the top of our list this year include
ensuring access to and support for
vaccinations including voluntary
vaccination such as covid-19 or
influenza but also routine childhood
vaccine for school entry measles polio
the types of vaccines that have kept our
children safe from very dangerous
infectious
diseases safe and effective
immunizations have prevented millions of
illnesses disabilities and deaths
immunization has led to the eradication
of diseases such as small ox and
historic low numbers of diseases like me
measles or Hepatitis B it's the way our
communities and individuals take care of
themselves and their neighbors and their
classmates we have seen in other areas
across the country where viruses such as
polio have crept back into the community
after Decades of protection while the
department does not intend at this time
to add any new immunization a
requirements um maintain but we are
interested in maintaining the ability to
adopt rules to adjust the required
vaccines for schools and child care
these are necessary to protect the
health and safety of all New Hampshire
kids including those who cannot be
immunized due to their own health
conditions and it prevents the kind of
devastating outbreaks of things like
polio and measles that our grandparents
and our great grandparents lived through
and sadly took the lives of their
classmates friends and siblings we all
appreciate New Hampshire's unique
culture of Live Free or Die and our deep
respect for privacy and autonomy um so
we look forward to a rich discussion on
how we honor those tenants ensure
transparency in process and do not put
our children unnecessarily In Harm's Way
when it comes to kids not only do we
care about vaccines we also deeply care
that families have the support they need
to thrive especially access to early
childhood and prevention initiatives
such as family support and home visiting
public health is continuing to work hand
inand with colleagues across the
department and in our communities to
make sure that Wick families have access
to farmers markets for fresh fruits and
veggies or Family Resource Centers that
are strong enough to keep their doors
open and every family that would like
home visiting services in those
critically important years can get it
and when we do it right using
evidence-based programs and data
informed strategies we find that moms
and babies are healthier children are
better ready for school families are
more
self-sufficient and with access to
referrals and concrete supports kids are
safer
we need to invest in that kind of
prevention from both an economic point
of view and a public health point of
view if we can prevent adverse childhood
experiences from ever happening in the
first place we will turn the tide on the
increases we've seen that are costly in
chronic diseases and behavioral health
problems and finally public health and
Medicaid have been strongly aligned in
supporting access to labor and delivery
services in every corner of the state in
face of significant challenges
decreasing populations recruitment
challenges for qualified staff and the
rise in costs many of our smaller
critical access hospitals have closed
their labor and delivery units leaving
young families with increasing travel
times to get to the most basic of care
there is an entire swath cutting across
the middle of the state not just the
North country straight through the
middle of the state that does not have
access to basic maternity care not only
has that created a Public Health crisis
of babies being born in unplanned places
in the emergency room at home even on
roots to the hospital putting both the
mother and the baby at significant risk
it also creates challenges for these
communities as families and businesses
make decisions on where to live and
where to set up shop it's hard to
attract young workers when there is no
place to get basic Medical Care together
with Medicaid we are looking at options
for appropriate rate setting postnatal
care and relationships between bigger
hospitals and smaller hospitals
opportunities for integrated
cross-disciplinary Obstetrics and
pediatric teams this is really a problem
that is solvable together
so in wrapping up we would just like to
remind the committee that we are focused
on improving the health of the people in
your community by ensuring Access to
Health Care promoting the conditions
that make it easier to live healthy
lives by detecting preventing and
responding to infectious and chronic
diseases and making sure we have
credible transparent and actionable data
this is how we serve your community you
will will hear from us often and we hope
that you will reach out to us with your
policy questions and your constituent
concerns thank
you thank you it's quite a quite a lot
of information yes thank you there
haven't been any questions to date I
don't believe did you have any we have
any questions
you good morning good morning for the
record my name is David weeders
Information Services director for
DHHS thank you very much for having me
today I will be very brief in comparison
to director Trisha Tilly um my my role
here in the organization is really to
lead the strategic planning design
interoperability for it manage and work
across the whole department for security
information security and in partnership
with data privacy so you'll see myself
and Ernie Gillan the deputy director for
Information Services in discussions
alongside the program areas supporting
the it and and the information
technology and the information Services
components of any legislation that is
presented um we do have several other
areas that aren't
really as as
um pertinent to legislation but they
support all the programs and services in
the department Department including pro
project management office where we're
implementing a a standard best practices
project management strategy for all of
our projects in the department
information security and awareness um
that was led by Elizabeth
gillet um our Deputy Information
Services off security officer uh data
warehousing and analytics is managed by
our our Mark Holk and he's really
managing all the data governance that
we're putting in place across Ross all
of our different systems to manage the
privacy and security of the information
that we manage and then our last area is
application hardware and life cycle
management which is led by Jim fenmore
for really managing all of our systems
as they go through a normal process of
implementation utilization in operations
and then retirement and replacement um
going through just like anything else um
hardware and software has a life cycle a
beginning and end and then a replace
placement process one person I didn't
introduce was Dave Hobson the project
management office director so thank you
you good morning good morning my name is
Karen heer and I am the director for the
division of Economic and housing
stability the division of Economic and
housing stability consists of several
different programs and
bureaus and our whole scope and
objective really is looking at serving
individuals and families from birth
through their
lifespan we apply a whole person or
whole family approach to services and in
consideration of determinance of health
and its
impacts we seek to improve access to
services and effective Service
delivery we focus on Human Service
integration and Alignment through a
customer
lens we utilize a shared leadership
model and a commitment to team
collaboration and system
design we Foster our community partner
synergy
to meet the needs of vulnerable
populations in the
state some of our major ongoing
initiatives at this time include
preparing for the unwinding of Medicaid
continuous
enrollment we also are working on a
number of initiatives to try to mitigate
the cliff effect which is essentially
when
individuals who are uh receiving Public
Assistance seek employment or perhaps a
promotion and the increase in their
earnings then be they become ineligible
for certain Public Assistance but often
times the increase in their earnings
does not match what they were making or
receiving rather for public assistance
this is known as the cliff effect and
this is the reason why a number of
individuals who receive public
assistants are not able to obtain
employment or take a promotion so we're
working on a number of initiatives to
try to mitigate that because we want
people to seek employment and pursue
careers or things that they really want
do we're also working on a number of
initi initiatives with respect to food
and security so trying to address access
to services with Outreach programs
making access easier for people um but
also working on uh ways that they can uh
receive uh programs like SNAP benefits
and um address some of the food in
security issues that they
have we also are working on
strengthening the child care industry in
New Hampshire so Child Care is an area
that I oversee and really looking to
work with a number of pilots and
initiatives we have in the Bureau of
Child Development to strengthen our
relationship with the business community
uh obtain professional development for
child care
providers try to seek ways of of
creating opportunities for startups or
strengthening existing facilities
particularly in what's known as child
care deserts so areas where families do
not have access to child care um or they
so I have several bureaus within the
division and one of them is the Bureau
of family
assistance the Bureau of family
assistant uh has all of the eligibility
staff and processes all the applications
for different Public Assistance programs
there are many of them uh and that is
our field operations which is services
are provided in the district offices
the bureau chief for family assistance
field operations was not able to join us
here this morning her name is Amy
Newbury and she's working very hard in
trying to make sure that staff are well
prepared so we can manage the Medicaid
enrollment we also in the Bureau of
family assistance have the bureau chief
Deborah sorley I'm not sure Deborah made
it um
and she oversees what I refer to as the
policy and business side of the house
she oversees the administration of the
snap
program the administrator for the snap
program is Bridget dukette she may come
before you from time to time with regard
bills Deborah also oversees the uh uh
program of the temporary assistance for
needy families also known as
TANF Carol Provost is the administrator
for the TANF program uh so she may from
time to time come before you as
well I also oversee the Bureau of fam of
excuse me employment
supports which is there to assist
individuals who are enrolled in snap or
tanif to gain employment and or
education particip participants are
provided case management career planning
work activities barrier reduction
employment Support Services to help them
prepare for obtain retain and Advance
their employment with me today is the
bureau chief from the Bureau of
ran we also work with employers and uh
educational and training organizations
to address labor market needs through
training and education Jean patod is the
administrator that oversees this part of
the Bureau of of employment supports and
today we lead a whole family approach to
jobs model in these
services and are working on different
strategies to mitigate the cliff effect
well I also oversee the Bureau of Child
Development and Head Start
collaboration this Bureau provides
access to amilies to the New Hampshire
Child Care scholarship program which is
child care
assistance it provides support and
professional development opportunities
to child care
providers helps parents make informed
choices and access information to
support their child's
development the bureau enhances the
quality of child
care The Early Childhood Workforce and
in an effort to improve a child child's
Readiness for and continued success in
school the bureau chief of this Bureau
was not able to be here today but her
name is Deborah Nelson and you may see
her from time to
time the Bureau of Child Support
Services uh is not a bureau that
typically comes before this committee
their business often goes before the
children and family law committee
nonetheless they do work with all of the
other
bureaus child support services are
provided to amilies of children whose
parents or the parent and caretaker do
not reside in the same household
together this is one of the largest
income support and anti-pry programs for
families the bureau engages and assists
parents who are willing and able or
unable to support their children and
when necessary enforces the
responsibility with parents who are
unwilling the bureau processes nearly
$80 million per year in support this is
private money not government all child
support payments are distributed and
dispersed within 48 hours to families
business hours of the receipt of those
payments which lessens the need for
governmental
assistance finally I have the Bureau of
housing
supports the Bureau of housing supports
bureau chief also is not here today and
this is not typically a committee that
she would present to uh nonetheless uh
her name is Melissa
Hatfield and the Bureau of housing
supports assist individuals and families
who have housing instability or
homelessness to access uh Housing
Shelter and other services to assist in
achieving in achieving or maintaining
housing stability and
Independence your community-based
contractors we provide short and
medium-term rental assistance and
permanent suppor of housings to
individuals Youth and families with
Support Services to maintain housing
stability we provide Outreach Services
to the hard-to-reach individuals such as
those who reside on the streets or other
places that are not meant for human
habitation to increase transitions to
housing
stability we provide intensive Case
Management Services to connect
individuals and families to services
including Medical and Mental Health Care
Tana for SNAP benefits Social Security
and other necessary
Services we are the collaborative
applicant for the balance of State
Continuum of
Care not also also not with me today is
a deputy director for this division as
the position is currently
vacant Brian Clark uh who is the
legislative liaison for the division
will also come before you from time to
time providing the division with a
tremendous amount of support you may see
uh The Division come before you with
respect to child childcare related bills
uh food and security related bills um
for
presentation thank thank
you oh okay yes
question um Can can I ask a question
sure go ahead oh yes I I wonder you
mentioned Cliff effect uh and that you
have some strategies could you briefly
tell what actually you can do to help
yes that's that's accurate but uh what
exactly uh does can can you do to help
people uh to overcome Cliff effect yeah
sure so some of the strategies that
we're doing were testing just to see if
they are truly effective and that some
of those will take one two maybe even
three years to complete uh and and
analyze so for example with respect to
the tanif program which is Cashes syst
Children what we are piloting is a
disregard of um new income for a period
of time so that they would continue to
be eligible for tanif and be able to
receive that new income at the same time
to strengthen their financial ability
and financial status so that they can
continue on with without the public
assistance in the future so that's just
an example um this past uh last
legislative session we had also
increased the um uh poverty level for
eligibility for snap it was at 185 up to
185% of federal poverty level which now
it's at
200 that will actually make a number of
a few thousand children eligible for the
snap program which also is intended to
strengthen those
families thank
you yes representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair um I've been trying to
understand our rental assistance status
as a state for a while now and I I see
it in different pieces and I was
wondering if before you came to division
3 uh the department if you could answer
you know be prepared answer four
questions and we can take them offline
um what are the number of rental units
in New
Hampshire uh what is the percentage of
those rental units that are receiving
some form of rental assistance from
either the federal or the
state uh what is the average rental cost
in New Hampshire and what is the average
amount of the rental assistance per
beneficiary
and I I don't think you're prepared to
answer those today but I but I'd love to
know what those are uh I'd also like to
just thank you for taking a look at this
Cliff effect I it you know I think
anyone who's looked at welfare payments
knows it's a it's a real issue and uh
it's getting in the way of people going
on with their lives so thank you thank
you for your questions and I will get
you some information to answer
those I could make a comment about the
cliff fact also um investigating welfare
fraud for 23 years in many cases
because they they were struggling
financially even after they went to work
they didn't report it and that was a
violation of Law and resulted in over
insurance benefits and prosecution in
many cases so uh so it's it can be a
problem
certainly thank you I have some
pragmatic questions actually I there
were two two statements between yourself
and a previous
presenter that really resonate with me
I've been working with people with
complex disabilities for the last 35
years of my life the cliff effect is Big
fragmentation in health care is big and
the prag the pragmatic question I have
is what role do we as legislators have
to collaborate with you to help work on
those
problems there is a great deal of
opportunity moving forward to work
together in
addressing the Mitigation Of The Cliff
effect if not the elimination of it um
so certainly being able to work with us
with some proposed strategies uh that we
would need your support on uh and any
particular bills that bring forward the
uh any other attempts to mitigate the
cliff effect greatly appreciate your
support because what I'm thinking about
actually is creation of legislation
going forward and and you know
Grassroots talking about that kind of
collaboration what opportunities are for
that y I would be more than happy to
have a deeper conversation with you
offline if you'd like to um and then
sorry go ahead joh and and chairman
McDonald thank you very much uh for this
opportunity John Williams from uh the
department and we do have other
presenters and speakers that are coming
and our contact information is fully
available and we look forward to a
robust opportunity of working with your
committee members uh but just being
mindful even though we're slightly ahead
of schedule still uh we have quite a few
other program areas that would like to
introduce themselves to you sir sure
absolutely representative Merchant you
had a question uh if you may thank you
Mr chair in regards to the cliff effect
how much of this is controlled by the
state how much is controlled by the
federal government because obviously the
state we can do something about the
federal we can't so before we spend a
lot of time in this Arena how much of it
actually is controlled by us here in New
Hampshire versus what's coming out of
DC so it depends on the program so we're
looking at different initiatives in
tanif for family assistance which there
are indeed some uh components to that
that are controlled by the state through
state law or administrative rules so we
do have some wiggle room or flexibility
if you will Child Care is another area
uh that we do have some flexibility in
to address uh with respect to
eligibility and then also uh through the
snap program supplemental nutrition for
uh assistance program we do have some
flexibility there as well as we just had
uh made some changes to eligibility this
last year so we we do have some
flexibility there not completely but
yes okay thank you thank you attorney
Williams thank you thank you very
morning good morning chairman McDonald
good morning members of the committee um
for the record my name is Henry Litman I
am the state's uh Medicaid director um I
have a handout coming around to you at
uh with some basic information about uh
the division of Medicaid services um and
contact information because I'm sure
during this session they'll be many
times you'll have questions about
Medicaid
um think think it's made its way around
the everybody have one yeah you may want
uh M Mr chair uh yes sir are are these
uh presentations going to be online or
digitally available I i' I'd like to
distribute to division 3 it's such great
information uh I would hope so that
would be I believe a Christina Dyer
question I don't know if she's watching
right now but um I'll I'll ask um I'll
that so justest that a high level um my
contact information's up top there uh on
Medicaid Finance issues we work with the
division of finance Athena gagnan is um
the finance director who works with me
um just the last bullet on the first
Pages just if you're looking at budget
material how to find the
division
um page two um the page numbers are in
the you see in the upper right hand
corner here um
um I believe um some of the individuals
on this list may not be here yet because
of uh a little bit ahead of schedule but
uh Rob Barry who is our Medicaid legal
counsel um I know he works with
representative Merchant on some some
matters um Dr Sarah finny can't be here
today she's our Medicaid uh Dental
director she's actually working on the
implementation of what was passed last
session with CMS today on uh the
implementation of the adult Dental
benefit uh don Landry who's our uh
policy administrator I don't know if Don
has made it here yet but Don um is our
eligibility subject matter
expert and I do know that our two uh
pharmacists uh Peg Clifford and Lee fan
are sitting in the back um often work
with um this committee um on matters
related to Pharmaceutical
and um new uh developments and and
treatment like gene therapy and and so
forth on page three is a summary
organizational chart of the division of
Medicaid
services and um gonna spend a little
time on page
four sometimes it can be a little
confusion confusing in terms of who's in
front of you for what what reason
um I as the in the the role in my
division and are here uh usually on two
fronts one is for like the insurance
programs like um people who get their
health coverage through the Medicaid
Managed Care
organizations um the dental
program um other areas of the department
like long-term services and support um
the uh mental health division of
Behavioral Health
um the Rob um Joe ripon's division
DCF um El ltss we're we're basically the
supporting financing arm to to those
services that can um with rided funding
meaning Medicaid funding and general
funds and sometimes other grant money
that we support them in that role and
are sort of the the key contact with uh
CMS centers for Medicaid Medicare
Services sometimes you'll see it
abbreviated as cmcs which is uh the
basically the part that deals with both
the children and the adults under
Medicaid and they want a prime contact
um a single point of contact for the
state with respect to Medicaid I I serve
in that role I certainly work in
partnership with all the other division
directors um and
U you know I think in terms of uh the
program today um we're almost at 250,000
individuals covered by Medicaid
um prior to the federal Public Health
Emergency dating back to March of
20120 middle of March when things kind
of fell into place
federally we were closer to
180,000 um I'm going to speak to that a
little bit more on one of the slides
coming up um in fact I'll I'll address a
little bit on Slide
Five so as a function of uh uh federal
law um through uh uh just recent
enactment of the Consolidated
appropriation Act of of
2023 which you may remember um or hear
heard about is that $ 1.7 trillion doll
bill that passed through Congress just
before the end of the year it contains
some Medicaid provisions and one of them
was
um addressing a priority of of New
Hampshire as well as other um
states that uh there'd be a decoupling
of the continuous coverage from the
federal public health emergency and you
know we've been at this for will be
close to three years where there's been
continuous coverage what that meant is
that an individual didn't necessarily
need to complete an eligibility renewal
in order to maintain coverage and that
was I think a federal policy to protect
against what were the health concerns
related to the the federal Public Health
Emergency um if I can just jump ahead
and come back a little bit but if you go
to slide um last two
slides I didn't put a page number on
those
apologize
um the the second to last page gives you
the status as of the end of December
which we had just just under 200 49,000
people at that point um there areund if
you look at the leftand
Circle um there's 10
12,482 people who have been what we call
in a protected status meaning because of
the continuous coverage requirements
under federal law that uh they needed we
could not uh disenroll them or otherwise
we'd forfeit the enhanced Federal
funding we've been getting during this
three-year period
no no state in the country had uh has
gone forgone that and as a result of the
legislation um starting April 1st um
individuals um who are in that protected
status um will start to do what we call
the unwind which means that individuals
in that group who
don't uh complete their eligibility or
may have um aged out of Medicaid or may
now be over income that they run the
risk of of losing
coverage um on the right hand circle on
that second to last page we know um the
the lighter shade is about almost 30,000
people
29,95 in this page that are pending and
eligible which means we have information
today that suggests that they no longer
are eligible as I mentioned over income
um maybe now over Medicare eligible Etc
um we have to go through certain
procedures before we can do that in fact
um next week we'll be meeting with CMS
to review our unwind plan to make sure
they're um consistent with Federal
guidance one part of the guidance is
that you can't disenroll everybody at
the same time you have to um do it uh at
about a one nth of your enrollment at a
time and the reason reason for that is
that the eligibility team which Karen
who was just up here um runs that group
that they want there to be normal
operations in other words um
redeterminations is is a heavy workload
to to complete that they want to make
sure that states get back to a sort of a
a more even distribution and don't have
a bolus of redeterminations where they
don't do a good job
on um the number of people that will
will lose eligibility well we'll deal
deal with um having to deal with 1 nth
we would expect in the earlier periods
of that unwind that more people we're
going to we've tried to prioritize those
individuals that we know that aren't
eligible to do those un wines first
versus people that for example maybe in
a nursing home or what what have you uh
that you know they may be not completing
their eligibility because of
circumstances we we've been doing a lot
of Outreach in fact I think New
Hampshire is looked to in the in the
country is doing one of the best jobs
and trying to make sure that those who
deserve to remain who are eligible
remain covered and those that aren't to
to work that through the last page sort
of gives you a a snapshot at the end of
December of that 10,000 where they fall
um one of the concerning areas for me um
and I and I expect for you are the ones
sort of on the right hand side of that
chart that there are nearly 35,000
children that are at risk of of losing
eligibility if um family members who are
their responsible party do not do their
eligibility paperwork um we're doing
Special Outreach
we've called every household that we
could call some in some cases where
there's um some of what I'll call the
the more um challenging eligibility
people who might have mental illness or
U might have a disability what have you
um
are part of one of our waiver programs
are in long-term care that we're doing
extra extra work and we've um worked
closely with the provider community and
our mcos to to uh reach everybody we can
multiple
times I could just jump back now to uh
Slide
Five um item two on that
list was what was passed last
legislative session we're in a good
place with respect to um implementing
what was passed legislatively we um have
an April 1st date for implementing that
we've made progress of submitting all
the state plan amendments and waivers to
um accomplish what was in the
legislation we've um entered into a
contract with Delta Dental to provide
the the network and the and the
insurance component of it and so I just
wanted to share with you what was past
last session part by this committee and
and finance and so forth that we're well
on our way there this committee also
last session um uh put forward the um
increasing the income limits related to
the in andout program this is people
these are people in the mental health
center space who have to incur medical
bills of a certain level in order to to
gain Medicaid coverage so they in andout
describes what's happening to to them
they get eligibility temporarily
depending on their expenses and we had
not raised the um the income thresholds
for a long time and so the legislation
um that was enacted is increasing those
and that went into effect January 1 as
required under the
legislation um the next one on the list
is the U what is sometimes known as
Medicaid expansion the New Hampshire
granted Advantage healthc Care Program
uh authorization that uh there's been a
commission that made recommendation on
that I suspect you'll see legislation on
that uh Topic in the near future um and
that uh if there's not a reauthorization
that occurs by December 31st that
end last session um number five was the
postpartum uh
coverage um since the the the
legislature had agreed to that but there
was some difference in on another
portion of a bill in the committee of
conference that Committee of conference
piece did not uh fail because there
wasn't a signature on that um but what's
changed as a result of the Consolidated
appropriation Act is that when we cons
when it was considered last year by the
committee um there was a 5-year limit on
how long that enhanced Federal match
would be available the the Consolidated
appropriation act um did away with that
5-year
limitation and so now if the state
adopts it it's permanent um be happy to
share with the committee the there's a
nice uh chart that I had shared map of
of the United States where this has been
adopted basically what they're providing
here is rather than just someone who's a
woman that's pregnant who delivers a
baby having 60 days of coverage Post
delivery it would allow for a year and I
won't get into the reason so much for
that but it's it's good for um mother's
uh uh health conditions and caring for
their child have the extended coverage
if you get on the eastn seab board New
Hampshire is the only state that has not
adopted that yet although we we came
very close last session um another
provision that was in the um end of year
package
was effective um January 1st of 24
children who are um under 19 years of
age will have continuous coverage for
year so that was a a component um that
uh all states will have to to provide
for um I'm sure this session you'll see
um issues come up on Medicaid rates um
Home Care is an area where obviously
there are Workforce shortages um
ambulance uh we we were able to last
session um pass an increase to bring our
Medicaid rates up to 50% of Medicare um
if you've followed the news recently um
Maine um had a blue ribbon commission
they they're struggling ambulance
coverage uh is experiencing some of the
same Workforce
shortages and uh I would imagine that we
might see something there um maternity
was discussed uh previously by by um our
director of Public Health it's an area
that we collaborate closely on um
substance use disorder um particularly
the um Residential Services we've made
some improvements in that space But I I
suspect that you may hear about those
issues as well as uh our community
mental health
centers um I don't have anything
specific there but I'm just trying to um
raise awareness that we may
have conversations about that the
department and its agency budget
included uh $20 million in terms of the
division of Medicaid services the
insurance programs $20 million over
the um the the B the next bium to to
deal with rate changes and we didn't do
anything more specific than
that uh lastly um you may be interested
and again this is not an exhaustive list
I just thought this would be good at as
an introductory meeting um you know
waivers and state plan amendments that
our division through um the policy unit
does a lot of the work to stand up the
state plan amendments that are are
brought
forward um one of a special interest I
think is the waiver that we received uh
in 2018 that allowed us to get a better
Federal match and provide for imp
patient substance use disorder services
and subsequently last June the extension
for uh psychiatric inpatient Services um
that waiver um is a combined waiver
began in
2018 we have a a renewal request in um
currently and also have included a a
portion in this new waiver request to
provide some support on a pilot basis to
uh the State Correctional facility for
people transitioning out of jail for
example who are in a treatment for sud
or or mental health to make sure that
they get um plugged
into um providers in the community
before they leave uh the state
correction system so that there's not a
gap that leads them you know ending back
up with a
problem and lastly uh work with uh um
achieving a support of housing uh waiver
which we received in September we're
working with some other states in terms
of how to work on implementing that but
basically it's not for rent it's for PE
individuals with mental health or
substance use disorder conditions who
need extra wraparound supports to be
able to
maintain themselves in um housing in the
community and let me stop there and take
uh yes representative thanks um I have a
question about Outreach um the
application for Medicaid is stressful
challenging at times especially for the
group of people that we're talking about
um I'm curious two things number one
what type of Outreach Services you have
and and more importantly at least I
think from this perspective is what
percentage of your budget is attributed
that if you can answer that so in terms
of the last part in terms of uh Outreach
um I don't have that separately
identified what I can tell you for
example with Community Mental Health
Centers
um we've provided the if a person is
attached to a Community Mental Health
Center we've provided them information
back on their their clients or their
patients in terms of what was
outstanding for them to comp complete
their eligibility
renewal through that effort just since
June for example we've been able to
Across the program get 25,000
individuals to do their redeterminations
on a voluntary basis before they had to
we've also been able to identify about
1,200
individuals who um voluntarily when
contacted them asked them do you still
need your your Medicaid have said I
don't I've got something else uh that
we've done so we've been um doing
Outreach through sort of existing
providers through through our own phone
calls we we beefed up the eligibility uh
section by bringing in through the
executive Council and using uh believe
ARA
funds um beefed up our call center to
free up staff to be able to do that
Outreach that was about a $3 million
investment um
that we made and there's an additional
request in for additional arer
dollars so that's about more than 25% of
the people on State on Medicaid correct
um currently it's about one and five and
a half individuals are on Medicaid um
typically we're one in seven you know
compared to for example Vermont or Maine
they're typically one in four so New
Hampshire generally has a a lower
um you all set I think so yeah okay okay
presentative oh I'm sorry go ahead thank
you Mr chair and thank you director
Litman for taking my question um I
erroneously thought that in recent years
all of Medicaid was protected so could
you just briefly in case I missed it
what differentiates protected versus
unprotected
currently um so there are individuals
all along the way during the three-year
period have you know taken an interest
to do their redetermination um
irrespective so they've they've re they
they proved that they have eligibility
so there's no no risk to them if you
will we've encouraged all along for
people to continue to to do eligibility
redetermination so that they didn't have
a
risk thank you yes go
ahead thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
is the bulk of Medicaid Health Care
Services that's the first question if I
may follow up with the yes Miss liit so
in terms of our capitation arrangement
with the mcos the current contract to
cover this current year is a $1.3
billion contract which you know um in
terms of the the health care component
approximately 90% of the the capitation
payment we pay is for the Healthcare
Services paying providers there's uh
88.3% uh administrative uh overhead that
we pay to the mcos for um the the
granted Advantage population and 7.6 for
standard um there's a 2% premium tax and
a 1.5% budget profit the reason I asked
the question is the fact
that when we look at critical access
hospitals in state of New Hampshire as
providers
um it's not only the fact that the
patient loses the coverage it also means
the impact of the critical access
hospitals financially can you speak that
for me please yes
um the fact that someone has coverage
means that if they provide the service
it doesn't go to a bad debt
so if you look at potentially um you
know our our initial estimates are that
of the 100,000 102,000 that potentially
60% of those
individuals won't retain eligibility so
we're talking about a population of
60,000 or so people that have some risk
of of
Eligibility um that when they use
hospitals or doctor's offices or what
have you that those providers um um
won't have to absorb that in a different
way assuming they have a mission of
serving all I think particularly you
know the vulnerable popul ations
uh who we know use Healthcare um and
we've done analytics on that as well in
terms of making sure that the the people
that are consuming a lot of healthcare
that we give ourselves the most time to
to make sure that they've had a fair
chance to prove their eligibility for
for their reasons and for the provider
community that we rely
on okay other
questions I actually had it I'm sorry
somebody have their hand up
okay I'm really sorry more not sorry but
I am thank you Mr chairman I really
apologize for not saying that earlier I
have one more question that's really
important Ashley what do you have any
numbers on what percentage of providers
in this state do not accept
Medicaid um I I can do some I'm off the
top of my head no um but we do can tell
you that enrollment within the providers
in Medicaid we have 30
th000 providers enrolled in Medicaid for
the state somewhere about that number um
those that aren't enrolled I think it
depends on the the specialty and but we
have all the hospitals all the major
medical groups um so you do have all the
hospitals now you do have all the
hospitals
yes okay I actually had a couple of
questions myself um are you are you also
a representative okay um having been in
the department and dealt with
eligibility working closely with DFA
over the course of my career um the
redetermination um issue uh I know that
sometimes it was six months sometimes it
was a year does it does does that vary
or is it now pretty much a year on
Medicaid or year on Medicaid yes and
sometimes it can be there's a provision
related to snap that we can bring
alignment between those um at times so
that that's kind of maybe one variation
from theme but once that's established
it's a year okay
and what's the average uh length of time
that a a redetermination is passed due
is there an average you could give me on
that or want to make sure I'm
understanding your question in terms of
how much overdue are people that are on
this on average yeah how how overdue are
they um there could be people that are
overdue as much as three it'd be
approximately three years or less okay
um because of the The Continuous
eligibility and that's that's why we've
been since July of 2020 we've been
meeting nearly every week to figure out
we don't we want to make sure we don't
have like this um tsunami of Eligibility
to do that we can manage it so that we
don't fall behind and someone doesn't
lose coverage just because we can't keep
up with the pace is that in part due to
the pandemic or AB 100% related to that
the provision okay thank
you anyone
else okay thank you very much you're
good morning I'm Ellen the point I am
the CEO at New Hampshire hospital uh as
a primary role I also oversee Glen Cliff
home and uh as well as the path program
and will soon to oversee the uh forensic
Hospital which is slated to start
construction in the spring of this year
I will uh Circle back to New Hampshire
hospital momentarily because I do have
some other teammates who are here and
wanted to just take a moment to
introduce themselves as well um but I
will speak briefly about Glen Cliff Hol
uh path in the forensic facility first
uh Glen Cliff home as you may know is a
long-term care facility located in Glen
Cliff New Hampshire they have current
capacity as well as very close to
occupancy of
75 patients there um they primarily
serve older adults at that location who
require longterm level of care um and
also suffer from a severe mental
illness uh the path program as many of
you may know is a 16 bed transitional
housing program that has capacity for 16
individuals the individuals that are
supported at the path program come from
New Hampshire hospital and uh the path
program helps support them in finding
community- based housing and resources
so that they can discharge back into the
community the forensic facility as I
mentioned is slated to be built uh Start
begin Construction in the springtime of
this year with planned occupancy of 24
beds um we are currently working on our
operations plan for the forensic
facility and there may be some
legislative efforts that come forth in
the coming session that you may see in
terms of our ability to operationalize
that
program in terms of New Hampshire
hospital and again I'll be brief um
because New Hampshire hospital and in
the program areas that I already
discussed have far fewer bureaus and
divisions um although with uh New
Hampshire hospital Glen Cliff home and
path we have approximately 800 employees
so we are a very large portion of uh
DHHS overall makeup when you add the uh
forensic Hospital staff at some point in
the future when that becomes operational
it'll add about an an additional 100
employees for a total of about 900
individuals working between uh the New
Hampshire hospital Glen Cliffe path
Continuum of Care New Hampshire hospital
has current capacity for 154 adults we
recently through several uh efforts at
New Hampshire hospital increased our
capacity from 145 to
154 we understand that there uh is
significant need for these acute beds uh
across the state and really this level
of service and Care um we do try to work
closely with the Community Mental Health
Centers as well as the other designated
receiving facilities to try to have
individuals service either in the
community with those resources
or in an alternate uh receiving facility
to receive that level of care because
New Hampshire hospital um H you know is
in such great
demand um we have um some of our
challenges that we're facing currently
that you may hear about is some
significant Workforce related concerns
in some of our departments we have some
significant uh vacancy rates that we're
working closely with the department and
others to try to address and have been
working with them for the past um year
or so Co was a challenge for us and
continues to be um from a a hospital and
inpatient perspective but we have again
a great team um who has come together to
keep our patient population and our
staff safe um I I also mentioned um I
mentioned the word safety a couple times
I would say from a New Hampshire
hospital perspective our main goals as
it stands are uh patient and staff
safety as well as appropriate treatment
and care for those patients in need
those are um key and at the Forefront of
our decision making Staffing definitely
plays um into that so sometimes we have
to make some difficult decisions about
capacity to in order to maintain our
staffing levels um and provide the care
necessary to the patients we serve some
of the things that New Hampshire
hospital also wants to continue to focus
on in the coming uh year is increasing
services with PE for people with severe
mental illness um in the community to
better allow for stabilized patients who
are currently residing at New Hampshire
hospital to be discharged this will
obviously directly relate to our ability
to um admit other patients in need and
address uh some of the Ed boarding that
you may be hearing about currently um
another thing that we work with with
DHHS and um other other departments is
addressing affordable housing needs for
people with de disab AB ilities that's a
significant um concern for us and and a
discharge barrier currently again Co
exacerbated that concern so we're really
wanting to um partner with other folks
to try to figure out some housing
resources across the state so that we
can ease up the current patient
population at New Hampshire hospital and
again admit folks who are in acute
distress uh what I'd like to do is
introduce a couple of New Hampshire
hospital staff members who are here they
are a portion of the New Hampshire
hospital executive team New Hampshire
hospital has uh a really strong
executive team with various levels of
service and um years of service and uh
support so with me right now is um Cindy
babones she is our director of social
work she's also a newly appointed
legislative liaison so I'll give Cindy a
minute just a talk hi thanks um as Ellen
said Cindy babon is director of Social
Work and part of the executive team at
New Hampshire hospital and so my role is
really to focus on discharging patients
from the hospital the psychiatrists and
the nurses treat them and keep them safe
while they're impatient but people don't
leave until a social worker discharges
them so my role is also to Advocate with
all of the community stakeholders who
serve our population so when I
understand very much so that um barriers
to discharge from New Hampshire hospital
so advocating for housing um benefits
Mental Health Services that will enable
us to discharge people who don't need
care I'd also like to introduce Dr Jeff
officer hello um Jeff feder chief
medical officer at New Hampshire
hospital my role is to oversee the
provision of care uh psychiatric and
medical to our patients while they're
with us um you may uh see me testifying
from time to time on issues that relate
to mental health law involuntary
commitment law or professional practice
as it relates to the delivery of care to
patients with severe and persistent
mental illness um I've also been uh
active in the uh planning for the new
forensic hospital as has been our uh
forensic team which includes Dr Lano and
Dr mushett Who May uh testify here on
issues related to that um and I work
very closely with associate medical
director um uh Sam sweater who um uh may
also serve in this role thank you thank
you and lastly I'm just going to have
one other member of the executive team
stand his name is Brett Mason he is the
representative Edwards I'm sorry did you
have a question for do uh yes yes sir I
did this is for the CMO um I I've been
uh I've been curious and just have never
thought to ask what is our success rate
with our uh inpatient returning to the
community uh in a way in which they're
productive they're safe uh they're
they're competent are do we do we
experience much success rate or or or is
this a
habitually long-term chronic you know
there is no there is no um full health
it's just a ongoing requirement in
different settings what could you
describe that a little bit sure so I
would say that you know we do have a
population of patients who um are
one-time customers we definitely see
that and we stabilize them and they move
on to be stabilized in the community at
different levels of care and we
certainly have patients who are uh
frequent customers um but you know our
definition of success for those folks
also has to do with the amount of time
they spend outside our facility remember
that at one point in history um this
whole population of patients resided at
new Hospital full-time and so uh even
for those uh frequent customers the fact
that we're able to stabilize them and
that they spend most of their time
living in the community um is part of
our success
rate sure go ahead thank you thank you
do do you um do you maintain records in
a way in which you can sort of track
them longitudinally to know what the
long-term impacts of our our treatment
plans are and our and the lost the
community of care services or system of
care that we we try to wrap around
them I'm not I'm not sure that we report
on that quite the way that you're
describing but um I can go back to my
team and see what we can find that that
could try to answer that question a
quantitatively great thank you any any
other questions for this for the
doctor H yes representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman
I have many questions which I'll
save for later but two specific
questions it seems to me that being the
head of New Hampshire hospital is a
pretty significant responsib is this for
the doctor or for the this is for the
administrator of the are we all set with
the
doctor think we are okay thank you sir
thank you the question is why why are
they adding on
more
responsibility uh for you um uh when
there are major problems of that New
Hampshire hospital so that's one
question and I know that that you do
what you're told and that you don't make
those decisions so it's really more for
the commissioner for somebody else the
second question is how are we doing
follow up okay follow up that uh with
the patients who are being held in New
Hampshire hospitals illegally uh are we
making any uh inroads and and getting
those patients out of those General
hospitals and into New Hampshire
hospital are you speaking about patients
who are currently awaiting care and
residing in emergency departments
throughout the state yes so um as it
stands this morning the cue of
individuals adult adult who are awaiting
care is
41 um we have the anticipation of
approximately four admissions to New
Hampshire hospital this morning um based
on discharges that are occurring so we
quickly turn over our open beds to
ensure that we are as timely as possible
with meeting those needs we also you'll
hear briefly from Hamstead hospital
after me we collaborate closely with
them um as in certain circumstances they
have the availability to serve young
adults
um New Hampshire hospital only serves
individuals who are 18 and above um we
also are very well supported by the
commissioner and the rest of the
department to try to address these needs
and work through individual resources
and opportunities that exists to enhance
those resources so that we can turn over
our current beds um and accept new
individuals into those beds who need our
level of care as I previously mentioned
too with the other designated receiving
facilities they do have um often have
capacity to be able to accept
individuals and we try to communicate
with them um as often as possible to see
if they are able to offer any additional
relief to that that weight list as
appropriate follow up yes go ahead so
we're still breaking the law uh that's a
fact I can't really answer that question
I can
thank you very much thank you
representative go ahead one other member
that I wanted to briefly introduce who's
very new to his role having started just
last week but um the his role
notoriously has um been a a key
representation at these committees in
the past and he's as he picks up speed
I'm sure that you'll be seeing more of
him that's Brett Mason who is our New
Hampshire hospital Chief Financial
Officer any other
questions yes go ahead representative
thank you
chair um you said something amazing at
the beginning of your presentation you
said that you're fully staffed at Glen
Cliff is that correct uh no that's not
accurate so I wish that were the case um
Glen Cliff home has had some
difficulties with their Staffing as well
their current capacity is 75 and the uh
rationale for that is primarily based on
Staffing they do have a higher capacity
of um about 120
however you know we do strive to try to
work with local communities as well to
have those individuals needs met in
their local community community before
considering an admission to Glen Cliff
home thank you I was concern thinking
that you had some solution for the rest
of the state yes
representative um and how many children
are waiting to be admitted I don't have
that answer but I'm sure that Kathy
Collins um who is at I think right after
me be able to provide that inform thank
you very much thank you for taking my
question thank you any other questions
yes
representative I thank you um I've heard
a lot about exacerbated staffing issues
and so especially during covid do you
have stats as to why is it wage wage
related is it there are increased
staffing needs because of Co like what
have you been able to
pinpoint I don't have any specific
information in front of me however I do
think that it's a culmination of many
different areas I think that there was a
vast majority we started at New
Hampshire hospital of uh senior staff
members who were close to retirement and
chose that point in time to be able to
pursue that retirement um there you know
social work for example thankfully
there's been an increase call for
supporting mental health in communities
and particularly at the school system so
we did lose a significant amount of um
experienced social workers to education
systems which is great for the overall
system but of course um creates some
some limited uh resources at New
Hampshire hospital so those are just a
couple of examples I would say that pay
um is is a factor that um is being paid
close attention to by both the
commissioner um as well as the
governor's office and there have been
some efforts to try to equalize some of
those dis disparities um at this point
but um you know we do send tend to see
folks who are very interested in the
state's benefit package that helps us
often but I think one of the biggest
concerns is that um we're competing
against one another significantly from a
health care perspective there are as you
know I believe 35 or so hospitals
throughout the state of New Hampshire uh
New Hampshire hospital is one of those
entities we're all searching for social
workers we're all searching for nurses
we're all searching for providers um and
the pool is very very small um so you
know it makes a very difficult
circumstance for any of us or all of us
to be successful when we have such
constrained resources in the state
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair um for the folks who haven't been
following uh what we've been doing
legislatively with the nhh for a while
is there we used to have a horrible
problem with warehousing patients in
need in local emergency rooms awaiting a
bed in the New Hampshire hospital and
we've tried some policies to to smooth
out that uh patient flow um where are we
at now what what do you know about uh
the status of whether or not we have uh
prospective nhh patients uh being
warehoused and
ERS um so again I think you're you're
talking about the um q that that exists
for patients who require Mental Health
Services throughout the state so as I
mentioned uh briefly already um we do
again New Hampshire hospital does
everything in our ability to try to have
needs met and get patients out of EDS
into New Hampshire hospital to have
their needs uh you know their acute
needs um addressed however we are
working with some significantly
constrained resources as I mentioned
Staffing being one of them that is a
factor in why New Hampshire hospital hit
capacity is currently at 154 um in the
past it's been as high as
185 um again most recently we were able
to reintroduce nine beds back into
service but that was not because uh we
had additional staff to do so it's
because we uh spread our resources a
little bit broader to be able to open
those additional beds so um it's always
a continuous day-to-day effort to try to
get patients off of that queue and into
our facility and again we also try to
work very closely with the designated
receiving facilities some of which have
also had limited capacity as I
understand due to Staffing um over the
last two years um through covid so you
know any type of effort um that is made
across the state is definitely something
that New Hampshire hospital would
support in terms of additional resources
and um bed capacity followup
representative uh thank you I just so
you know I'm I'm I'm almost always very
impressed by the people that work at the
department that wasn't the answer to my
question though I I know you guys are
working hard and doing smart things I'd
like to know if we're keeping track of
how many patients are being warehoused
and ERS because we don't have the
ability to make them inpatients at nhh
for whatever reason and whether or not
that status of warehousing is
continually monitored so that it could
be potentially reportable yes that's
accurate we do H we do have a daily
queue that we monitor seven days a week
right now that Quee is 40 and we also
have information back
uh 40 yes um and we do have information
back
to many previous years as to how that
number has ebed and flowed over
time okay thank you did I see a hand up
over
here yes go ahead
thank you Mr chair um you mentioned
recently that um within recent history
you had as many as 184 185 um but I'm
more interested in your um further
history like the 1960s and70s um is it
my my understanding is please correct me
if I'm wrong that you know several
decades ago we had a much higher
capacity um can you explain if that is
the truth and if so why did the why and
how did the capacity get so limited and
when thank thank you so I might actually
call Cindy babonis back up our director
of social work uh she's been in her role
for the past couple of years but in
state service um as a social worker at
New Hampshire hospital for many years to
your your question yes um and Cindy can
elaborate a bit more but going back uh
decades there was thousands of
individuals Dr fter mentioned this as
well who were residing um on the campus
um and living there essentially and
really over time um we you know the
state made an effort to
deinstitutionalize individuals and have
them be able to return to their families
and their communities as appropriate
once they were stable and able to do so
can you speak more to that history sure
I mean it's a national history for
mental health treatment in the 1960s is
when deinstitutionalization began but in
summary it was the advancement of
treatment medications available or um
even just support systems in the
community so we set up the community
mental health system which provides
services intensive services to those
with mental health issues in their own
homes in the community so that they
don't have to reside in an
institution um but kind of to the point
of the queue and what keeps us from
getting more people in I think there
needs to be a stronger focus on getting
people who don't need our level of care
out of our facility because we do have a
good number of people that compete
competes with the number of people in
the queue that don't need our level of
care anymore and they can't leave
because we don't have the services in
the community to keep them safe in the
community we've had more of them in the
past and we've lost some of them in the
last 20
years okay representative you have a
question uh yes thank you Mr chairman um
please um correct me if I'm wrong my
understanding is that we in this state
have a functionally a hub and spoke
model where people come into an ER and
then they
assigned to one of several facilities
like I was under the understanding there
were eight different mental health
facilities are you one of those Aid or
issue so New Hampshire hospital I would
say um is
the area of service for the most acute
and most significant and severe mental
illnesses that um States individuals in
the state of New Hampshire have we kind
of see ourselves as as the facility of
Last Resort in that um you know we do
have a significant amount of um I'm
looking for the word uh limitations in
regards to where our patients can go um
you know different areas of access that
they can have um different levels of
supervision that they're allowed to have
all of which relates to where their
current state is in terms of their
illness and their safety so New
Hampshire hospital tries very hard to
accept the patients that truly require
that significant level of care and as
Cindy mentioned there are patients who
are awaiting a level of service that
could be served in another less
restrictive environment including one of
the designated receiving facilities ask
you want to follow up yeah I'm trying to
understand this system better so
um like if I come into a mental health
center for acute depression suicidal
depression I can go go to one of any one
of these eight places but if I'm you
know violent or something like that then
nope you don't go to these seven you go
to New Hampshire mental house was that
correct does that aggravate the queue is
what I'm getting at I I think one of the
in cend you can jump in I think one of
the other things to take into
consideration here is the vast majority
of patients who are currently residing
at New Hampshire hospital are there um
via a court order so they're there
essentially against their will um the
other designated receiving facilities
tend to take individuals who are
slightly less um severe might be
voluntarily seeking treatment or support
or might have a guardian who is um
getting that level of support on their
behalf okay um is a quick representative
Edwood we need to move on uh yes yes sir
I'm I'm just going to ask that when um
the New Hampshire hospital comes to
division three for the budget part of it
that uh we we think we've been funding
the system of care so that there's a
place to move patients out of your
facility into a step down environment
and so this is new news and if you could
be prepared to come tell us what what we
haven't done because we think we've been
addressing this problem so be happy too
thank you thank you representative and
um thank you very much thank you um
good
morning
microphone good morning good morning
it's working better uh nice to see you
those of you that I know I see some
familiar faces and nice to meet you
everybody else my name is Meredith tus
I'm the director of our division of
program quality and integrity and for
those of you that are familiar with the
Department you may recognize that name
or a relatively new division we were
created at the beginning of 2020 so
we're entering our third year so I won't
be able to say we're new for much longer
but some of you may be familiar with the
Department organization and this is a
newer division uh we consist of three
parts the Bureau of program quality the
Bureau of program integrity and the
office of internal audit the office of
internal audit um is currently an
unfunded position but that is exactly
what it sounds like they do internal
audits at the request of management and
report back to management on any areas
programs or functions that they would
like to receive a
review the Bureau of program Integrity
uh does all kinds of functions
internally and externally including um
monitoring our external service
providers mostly in a financial capacity
for contract compliance and we do
federal subrecipient monitoring we uh
Lia with program areas that are
receiving Federal audits to make sure
that they're responsive to the Auditors
and if there are any federal audit
findings that they're appropriately
followed up on we do fraud waste and
abuse on behalf of the Medicaid Program
and food stamp program for Medicaid
providers and for
beneficiaries uh and we also do food
stamp eligibility reviews which is a a
federally mandated review process where
we look at food stamp eligibility and
whether it was done accurately or not um
I think that is most of program quality
and on the program sorry program
Integrity uh program quality supports uh
all the programs across the department
but particularly Medicaid mental health
substance use disorder in uh
establishing quality metrics and doing
data analysis and data review and data
Integrity processes for the on behalf of
those three program
areas um program quality is also
involved in helping to
create uh audits of programs or service
providers as it relates to their
clinical quality or service oper
operation and that is the Bureau of
program quality and uh they're also
engaged in contracts quality management
which is where we work with the
different program areas in the
department to determine uh from a high
level how the contracts they're engaged
in align with their strateg IC goals and
what are the key performance indicators
that would relate to those strategic
goals and how are you going to measure
that as it relates to this contract to
ensure that the quality you expect from
this contract is coming through and that
is our Bureau of program quality and
those are our three
areas there any questions related to
that I see a hand up
somewhere just not program Integrity is
actually where I work to see you again
director good to see you representative
good to be
here no questions okay great thank you
you good morning thank you for having me
uh my name is Melissa Hardy and I am the
division director for long-term supports
and services um so in a in a nutshell we
work on um closely with Community
Partners and families and individuals to
meet their needs in the community so our
division is made up of three bureaus one
is the Bureau of Developmental Services
one is the Bureau of elderly and Adult
Services and we also have the Bureau of
family um centered services so I'll
start with the Bureau of Developmental
Services we have three
1915c waiver programs in the bureau bu
of Developmental Services which um one
is for children one is for folks with
developmental disabilities and the third
waiver um is for folks with acquire
brain disorders so those waivers um help
and support individuals and families to
stay in the community and receive
Services um to keep them in the
community um The Bureau also for uh
Bureau of Developmental servic has U
close Partnerships with area agencies
there's 10 area agencies throughout New
Hampshire that are Service delivery
system um so those area agencies
coordinate services with individuals and
families um contract with providers um
to to receive um and to coordinate
services for BDS we are currently um
undergoing a a systems change as we call
it so looking at four different areas
that we're currently working on um one
is looking at Medicaid rates what we're
reimbursing our providers um so we're
working with a a contracted actuary to
look at the costs and develop
rates we also are looking at our waiver
Services what are um included and what
could be included looking at other
states uh getting feedback from our
stakeholders and individuals that
receive services to see if we can
enhance what we have on those waivers
we're also um as part of this plan going
over our it system currently uh we have
a very Antiquated information technology
system where um I could say that we do a
lot of work in Excel spreadsheets to
look at our budgets and and do our
calculations so we're really excited to
have our it systems more automated which
will make um you know things definitely
easier and more streamlined and then
we're also looking at what we call our
intensive treatment services uh we
currently have folks that are being
served out of state uh because there
isn't enough infrastructure in New
Hampshire for those who require uh more
intense treatment services so we're
looking at building our capacity in New
Hampshire um so people don't have to go
out of state and also so we can bring
folks back into state to be closer to
their
families the Bureau of elderly and Adult
Services um is is a large um part of our
work as well part of uh Bureau and of
elderly and Adult Services is the um
Adult Protective Services which I'm sure
you've heard of so investigations of
reports of abuse neglect or exploitation
um so we have a a subdepartment for
those APS workers beas also has um a
1915 C Medicaid ww called choices for
Independence where folks um to be
qualified for that waiver have to be at
a nursing home level of care um but
would receive um community services so
they can stay in their Community versus
going into a nursing
facility theas also um manages our
service link which is our um aging and
disability Resource Center so their
physical locations in the community
where folks can make an appointment or
walk in kind of like a One-Stop shop to
um connect families and individuals with
services um do information and referrals
do some Options
Counseling um so we have Sur link we
also have um other um funding such as
the older Americans Act and the social
service block grants which fund things
like senior centers
Transportation uh meal Zone wheels or
congregate
meals um and other um and other services
to keep people in the community who who
may not necessarily meet medic level of
care and then our uh Bureau of family
centered Services there it's for
children with special Health Care needs
um so we have um intervention service
early intervention services for children
who are birth to three years old who
have a developmental delay um an
established condition or who may be at
risk for a developmental delay so that
Bureau really supports families in
helping their child grow and develop in
meeting their needs um in the community
um in achieving their goals so those are
our three um bureaus for the long-term
supports and Services I do have the
bureau chief for developmental Services
here Sandy
pheros and the bureau chief for elderly
and Adult Services Wendy
Alman and we also have our legislative
liaison for the Bureau of Developmental
Services Melissa
neth so that's what I have so thank you
very much for having me yes
representative we have a question
yes thank you Mr chairman also thank you
for taking the question in regards
to I understand this
correctly when we looking for elderly
and Adult
Services what is the state of New
Hampshire doing to try to encourage
people to age in place versus being
placed in a nursing home because for two
reasons one is that's where they want to
be and number two it's less costly
Absolut so what are we doing as far as
the state goes back to maybe
representative Edwards in the finance
committee but how do we somehow help
people shift from the nursing home care
to staying at home care and fund it
accordingly so we actually can save some
money and I'll help improve the
patient's care um I want to say I want
to start off thank you for the question
um recently um at the end of last year
the the bureau received um Federal grant
for Money Follows the person um I which
is you know to either transition folks
out of nursing homes into the community
or develop systems of care in the
community to keep folks into the
community so we're excited um that we
were awarded that Grant which will
provide um to employees in that in that
um program to help just that how do we
deliver a service of care to keep people
in the community as you said less costly
um you know our nursing facilities
certainly have Staffing concerns as well
uh but also our our community providers
have Staffing concerns so looking at um
the rates that we're providing or
reimbursing for our choices for
Independence waiver I think would be a
great place to
start thank you any other
you
morning good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee I am Kya Fox I
am the director of the division for
Behavioral Health and our division is
made up of four areas we have a policy
unit um and then we have three bureaus
and the bureaus are the Bureau of drug
and alcohol Services the Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health and the
Bureau of Mental Health Services which
addresses the adult population for
mental health services
we um I'm going to we have six people
here that I'm going to introduce and ask
them to stand um Diana Lacy is a uh
senior policy analyst within the policy
unit she focuses a lot um my colleagues
have come before you all morning and she
focuses a lot in working with Medicaid
and how Medicaid um can be a leverage
point for the PE the population that we
serve Jenny O Higgins is also a senior
policy analyst and she is our
legislative leis on um for for a lot of
things and so you'll be seeing a lot of
her if you don't know her
already Jennifer Sabin is also within
the policy unit she is the director for
the state opioid response program which
um is a Federal grant program uh that
funds our doorway system as well as a
number of other providers across the
state Rebecca Ross is the director of
children's Behavioral Health um she will
most likely appear um she also has been
a legislative liaison for many years
with the department and she also will be
appearing before other committees um
that deal specifically with children's
issues
Julian carban is our director of the
mental health the Bureau of mental
health services and uh she has been with
the Department um for several years
she's
um very um Adept at talking about our um
new New Hampshire rapid response system
we just marked the first year of that
new system which is a community-based
response mobile crisis response through
a Central Access
Point and then Philip Bradley is an
attorney with the Department he is um
embedded within the Bureau of mental
health services and he also is a
legislative liaison and acts um on
behalf of the division on many
legislative
issues we have our guiding principles
that come from plans and from blueprints
so everything that we come for you to
discuss ties into one of these plans if
not all of them and that includes our
10-year mental health plan which was
established in
2019 and we've made great strides as
mentioned the New Hampshire rapid
response uh mobile crisis was a result
um of one of the recommendations in that
plan we also have the children's system
of care and so again looking at
everything that we do being Guided by
the 10-year plan and the system of care
and then we also work very closely with
the governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs they um were essentially the
Fiscal Agent and um the executive
director of our Bureau of drug and
alcohol Services I the director is the
executive director for the Governor's
commission and so they have um an action
plan that they just established um later
last year
uh that's a three-year action
plan and um much of the thread this
morning addressed um substance misuse
and Mental Health Services when we think
of our division it's really focused on
the communitybased side and um we'll be
talking as we go through our budget and
with finance division 3 a lot more about
how those Community Based Services um do
um serve the purpose of uh diverting
people from entering a more acute phase
of
need and with that I'll
conclude thank you yes representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman um I'll try to make this into a
question uh the um you mentioned the
10-year plan and and as I understand
that that's updated Contin
L that could serve as a extremely
important document for both the health
committee and the finance division so
I'm wondering if if you could get the
most upto-date
plan uh for our committee and for
division and finance so that they could
use that as a policy guide uh for all of
the work work I did the last one as
chairman of the 10-year plan and not a
single thing was ever done uh so I've
been an advocate ever since that we
don't waste our money and that when we
have a a
very useful document that we should make
the best use of it thank you very much
and thank you for your good work so I'll
be happy to share um the 10e plan that
was established in uh 2019 as well as
the key accomplishments we also have a
document that accompanies that and it's
because of the Good Fortune of the work
of the governor and the legislature that
we have been able to make significant
progress um on this most recent 10-year
plan um the the previous one hit a
recession and so
so could could you get that document for
us absolutely we'll make sure we get it
to the committee I see another hand up
over
here
okay all set looks like we're all set
thank
you good morning good morning last but
not least hopefully uh Melissa saer I'm
the chief legal officer for the
department and I oversee the office of
legal and Regulatory Services which um
has a lot of different bureaus and units
and so I'll try make it brief the first
Bureau that um I oversee is the
regulatory side of things that is a
bureau of Licensing and certification
that has to do with uh Health Facilities
licensing and child care licensing um
here in the state of New
Hampshire that uh Dorene shakley is the
manager of the Bureau of Licensing and
certification and she is here she could
St she's over there in blue um so you'll
be seeing her as well as Danielle War
booys um they both are going to be
presenting in front of the committee uh
if there's anything Health Facilities uh
usually related uh child care licensing
is typically heard through Edna but um
here you will see um Danielle or um
Dorene present on on anything Health
Facilities related other than that I
also obviously oversee the legal
department uh the legal department
provides general counsel to all of the
bureaus that have presented today as
well as um they represent the department
at hearings either in uh the circuit
court system probate and also at um the
our administrative Appeals
Unit the administrative Appeals Unit is
also under my purview that has to do
with any kind of appeals if clients um
aren't receiving services or or want to
appeal decision made by the department
they can go in front of the aou um and
and um have a hearing and and um
obviously they can appeal any decision I
also oversee the two um budman's office
you which are um budsman units at the
department one is strictly for clients
so if clients have concerns um with any
of the bureaus in the department they
can go to the EMB budsman who will look
at uh the issue from an independent
perspective and help them with that
process and hopefully um you know Assist
the client in getting what they what
they need and then also the office of
long-term care on budsman which is uh
individuals who go into long-term care
facilities and assist in um helping with
concerns that they may have with their
long-term care provider uh so any
concerns related to the the residence
the you know the food I mean it really
could be anything the care they're
receiving the physician practices all
that kind of stuff so our our um our EMB
busman's office go goes and does that
work
um I think that's everything except for
legislative Services I also over um seee
some legislative Services although John
Williams um as most of you know uh
handles the bulk of that work but um for
big items um at the department things
that we'll have a significant impact you
will see me uh present in front of not
only this committee but many others uh
related to you know significant issues
that occur and I'm I'm always in the
background kind of assisting um with
with the legislative process so I unless
I have other questions I'll just um have
John come up and and close it out
representative Edwards I believe has a
question for you sure thank you Mr chair
I I think we just found the busiest
person in the department and uh I I I
think you at least used to have an
additional title of being the
Department's privacy officer is that
correct so I no there is a privacy
officer at the department they are in
the legal department um and that is
Kathy burnhard so she's always been the
privacy officer but but she reports up
to up through the legal department so
through me she reports to you is that
what you're trying to she reports to
Frank knockman who is the um head of the
legal Bureau who and then Frank reports
to me so we all we all take an interest
in privacy matters okay
thanks okay I think that's all did you
have a question okay I'll let John close
it out then thank you so much nice to
meet you all well chairman McDonald and
also your Vice chair represent Leon and
also our division three chairman
represent Edwards thank you for this
opportunity for those of you who have
done this before which I look around at
some smiling face is think thinking
thank goodness they were able to get
through 40 people in 2 hours period of
time we can only do such Miracles
working collaboratively with you um I
want to just say thank you for this
opportunity this is a great way to get
started just to see the people who are
going to come before your committee uh
and before we over stay our welcome too
long we are here uh to assist you in
whatever capacity we can as a resource
to getting you answers to the questions
and to work again collaboratively
together as your bills make their way
through creating policy here as they Al
when they're passing over in the Senate
your committee has just historically
done a tremendously good job and a lot
of great work has been done here so with
that uh I concludes my comments uh um
chairman McDonald and chairman Edwards
and vice chair represent lean thank you
very much for coordinating this and we
we really appreciate everyone coming
this morning and sharing the roles they
play and we look forward to working with
all of you
so and with that uh we're a little bit
ahead of schedule but we do have a break
allowed so why don't we we take a like
maybe a a 15-minute break and then come
be
e
away
please
yeah I think it's been more like 20
minutes but that's that's fine we've had
and
um Paula
manahan if you want to come
forward from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee um for the record Paula minan
Senior vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association and thank you chairman
McDonald for the opportunity to just
introduce myself um I do come in front
of this committee often as does my um
the president of the association you
will see him um periodically Steve anest
is um also a registered lobbyist as is
our Executive Vice President Kathy
Bizarro thunberg um and we have a new
member of our team Brooke Banger who
used to actually work at the department
under Henry Litman until May and now is
our vice president of financial policy
and compliance so you may see you will
see me most often but others as well um
and I just wanted to leave with you some
material and happy to go over um
any of this um offline or at any time in
the future and sometimes the bills that
come in front of you um this material is
relevant but I wanted to start off with
um every year we update the what we call
the hospital fa sheet so that is this
document um that has a lot of um
interesting tidbits about hospit the
hospitals all of our hospitals in the
state of New Hampshire um are part of
the association including the Community
Hospitals um which in comprise one
academic Medical Center Dartmouth
Hitchcock 12 large Community Hospitals
which we reference as PPS hospitals
which means the prospective payment
system under Medicare that is how
they're reimbursed and then critical
access hospitals are we have 13 of them
and then we list them um in the on the
fact sheet additional information has to
do with Community benefits and we
actually have a um a specific report
report on community benefits hospitals
um participate through the Attorney
General's office um doing community
needs assessment periodically and we um
we do an anal they do an analysis of
what are their top Community needs
assessments through their um surveys
with their with their communities so
that's information that we have in here
as well as something that is um we have
a infographic on barriers to discharge
um and I think um representative Nagel
and others were talking about this
earlier what of some of our challenges
trying to get patients out of the
hospital we did an analysis um this
Summer that has some interesting
statistics and are somewhat alarming um
relative to how many patients in a given
um month and a half or so are in the
hospital unable to get out due to um
inability to move them into um a more
appropriate setting
that means that there are a lot of
unnecessary impatient days unfortunately
a lot of unreimbursed acute care costs
because un um um one fact that I think
is important is as people are if there's
a
unmedicated and not by the third parties
so they are taking up a bed that
prevents others from getting in the
other important statistic and I know
some of you are um either retired um
Physicians or current um active
Physicians occupancy rates um over 90%
80 5% are are alarming and I understand
that there um so our occupancy rate
right now is very high um it has been
for some hospitals it's over 100% which
Yes means that they have more patient
patient in than they actually can can
put in a bed um that is why some of them
are in the emergency room unable to to
move out our critical access hospitals
our smaller hospitals usually stabilize
and get them into an acute uh L uh
tertiary care or one of the Community
Hospitals um the PPS larger hospitals
they can't do that because the PPS
hospitals have no no space um so that is
very concerning um and as it states here
we've seen at 100% increase since the
prepandemic levels relative to our
occupancy there is um on our website we
have a more detailed report and I'm
happy to share that with you but if you
want to just look at the more detailed
report it is on there the other um
infographic that we worked on this
summer B is based on um some concerns
that our CFOs had relative to the labor
costs and um we've talked a lot about
Workforce shortages hospitals um are in
the same boat that everyone else is in
relative to Workforce and what we have
had to um resort to is are use is using
staffing agencies which um have they've
always used staffing agencies but never
to the extent that they have to use them
now which is causing um an enormous um
uh labor cost um increase which this
infographic shows and again there is
another more detailed report on our
website and I am happy to um um get any
additional information for anyone that
um would be interested and I am I am uh
in the way of your lunch so I will um
stop there but happy to answer any
questions yes representative Edwards uh
uh thank you Mr chair I I think I have
two separate ones I'll come back to you
uh to request permission to continue but
um okay this first one barriers to
discharge uh I I think the graphic kind
of buries the lead uh the two the two
barriers that I'm seeing are barriers to
Guardianship and access to Medicaid for
long-term Services uh if those are the
two critical barriers we we just had m m
Hardy here from
long-term service support so I would
want to know to the extent to which you
all are working together because she may
be holding some solutions that could
help m
that yes um this is actually this this
survey that we did this summer was
specific to those two specific issues
there are many barriers to discharge and
we have had a more robust um reporting
in the past but we focused on those two
issues we actually set up earlier this
year and the department is participating
we have an inter Agency workg Group that
involves Miss Hardy and her um staff
that you were introduced to today so yes
we do have and um it also incl includes
the court system because of the
guardianship issue primarily Falls with
judge king and um and and um the pro the
probate court so we have been meeting um
roughly every two weeks for uh about
three or four months trying
to
identify um tools and opportunities
where we can improve on those on those
issues but we um we believe that we
needed to do this survey to just
highlight some of the challenges
specific challenges in getting folks out
of the
hospital follow up okay so this is this
is still in the same Vein on uh on on
the guardianship you're saying it's a a
lot of it's dealing with our court
system and I'm I I would just encourage
you if you've not already uh just set up
a meeting and talk to uh chairman Bob
Lynn of the Judiciary uh I I I think he
should have some situational awareness
to help overall great that's a comment Y
and then and then if I may uh a a
different question Mr chair yeah go
ahead okay so um on the other graphic on
the labor cost survey you site um
670,000
er patients Ed patients and this is a a
tie into to the earlier uh conversation
I was asking the new New Hampshire
hospital uh I use the term warehousing
they like the word q I think the the Q
obfuscates how horrible it is to
Warehouse these patients in the ER and
so so I'm curious as you guys are
looking at this ER issue to what extent
are the is the hospital Association you
know reporting up these this warehousing
problem and to and and where do you see
that information uh getting into the
hands of the legislature so that we have
some situational awareness going on are
you are you like bringing it to the HHS
oversight or anything like that so we
refer to them as Ed holds um and to we
put everything on our website so at
Daily we report um we update that on our
website um the nha.org and right now we
have about
179 Ed holds um um some are behavioral
health we have 53 I know New Hampshire
hospital said 40 but those would
probably be ieas um um inv voluntary
admissions um and some and we report
voluntary admissions as well and then we
have 21 pediatric behavioral holds so
yes all of that is updated on our
website and again um that's what these
barriers to discharge um include folks
that are it's not Co related it is just
that 179 folks cannot get into a bed of
some sort so
um I'm trying to remember if I answered
your question you did it was excellent
and you guys are way on top of it and
I'm not so if you could if you could
help me uh by uh emailing me the URL to
the direct site y uh and then I'll make
sure that everyone on oversight has it
all right thank you you're welcome okay
uh yes go ahead head thank you Mr chair
and thank you for my question Paul of
course
um as you know and we know Hospital
bottom lines are usually running at
margins of 1% if we're lucky unlike
other Industries and so you would say to
yourself if you're running at 110% which
Dartmouth was this morning you would say
how would they ever go out of business
because they're just full but we know
that because of shutting beds and
Staffing shortage and discharge
capabilities are diminished my question
is are we aware of especially as we are
looking at the potential for a Medicaid
expansion you know um stop um are we
aware of any hospitals that are in Risk
right now of potential closure um we
have shut down previously nursing homes
because of re reimbursements and you
know hospitals in the state have closed
so are we aware of any hospitals that
are in such a perilous position where
they may close at any point in the near
future um I do not have um I'm not aware
of that information how however you're
right representative Murphy that um they
are full but they're not um doing well
financially um and we are working
actually on our latest operating margin
report that I hopefully will have soon
that looks at that statistic and you're
it because they're full and but some of
them are not reimbursed
um um patients that is a big problem
because again you can't get them out and
you can't get folks in um so it is it is
um it's becoming a crisis um to be
honest um but as far as individual
hospitals closing not at this not at
this time but they are um in in Dire
Straits in some areas of the state for
sure and one thing thank you for
reminding me um one thing that we are
very supportive of in addition to
Medicaid expansion we are 100%
supportive of um permanent
reauthorization of Medicaid expansion
and more to come on that in the coming
months but um in addition to long-term
services and support we want to support
Medicaid rate increases for long-term
services and support to include nursing
homes as well as community- Based
Services because as someone has stated
it's not always appropriate to have an
individual go to a nursing home but of
course a lot of patients that are in a
hospital need a rehab bed um and some of
those are provided in um in long-term
term care facilities and sometimes they
just unfortunately just need to be in a
nursing home and we just there is no
Staffing available to staff those beds
safely in nursing homes so that I think
you will hear a lot more about in the
and certainly um during the budget phase
in um and then certainly in front of
your committee as well so thank
you okay did you have a question
representative
King thank you Mr chairman it's thank
you Paula Miss man nice to see you um so
uh welcome back thank you
and um this may take a little bit of
development uh so in August I had a
cranky gallbladder removed and um I I
will say that while I was in the New
Hampshire hospital Southern New
Hampshire I had very good care and uh
they eventually had to move me to
Massachusetts because uh Department
didn't have the beds for me so I I ended
up going to
Ley um who had the facilities to be able
to handle my cranky gallbladder um so
um while I was in there I found out that
there was an
entire Wing that had been shut down
because they just couldn't staff it and
I think this goes to what uh um
representative Edwards mentioned before
and um and the Young young lady I can't
remember her name um at the beginning
talking about you know how do we how do
we get uh um to supply the the the
nursing and the doctors that you need in
order to run the
facility uh so that's I guess that's my
main thing I'm looking at this from a
business perspective because that's what
my background was before I retired and I
I'm just now getting bills from things
that I did in
March and uh usually in business we get
thumped on pretty hard if we weren't
calling in our account receivables and
if um and I'm sure some of this has
something to do with the insurance
companies and and getting their response
before they can actually send out bills
to the customers but it you know if
you're waiting nine months for a payment
from me then I don't feel like uh
there's a real Rush on on getting paid
which in you know through what my work
on the committee I can tell you I can
tell anybody that you're definitely in
dire need of funding so um that's I
think I I I see several different
avenues that um you can grow in and I'm
just wondering if um you know from a
business perspective how are we handling
um uh the the Personnel to bill the
Personnel to be able to handle and not
close down wings of hospitals thank you
um when you mentioned uh closing can I
just I get a ask a clarifying question
were you referring to a wing being
closed at Southern New Hampshire Medical
Center or at Ley um at uh New Hampshire
I'm
sorry okay um so yes there are staff
beds and there are license beds and
that's your I think the the Crux of your
um comment so the hospitals are licensed
for a certain number of beds through
Health Facilities which you heard um
Dorian Shockley and Melissa St sier
oversee Health Facilities licensing the
staff beds are a diff is a different um
number and some hospitals have had to
limit their um their beds because they
cannot staff them again sort of like um
similar to long-term care not as acute a
problem I think as long-term long-term
care because they are paying those
outrageous um staffing agency rates to
bring in the nurses CU they have to um
and it's primarily nurses I shouldn't
say only nurses but primarily nurses um
so though that is one issue um and staff
and Workforce is a very important issue
I think what would be interesting is the
um through the Endowment for health the
forward fund um has been working on this
long on this issue for healthc care work
Force for a while and there is a lot
more information um relative to trying
to to figure out um long-term solution
short-term and long-term solutions to
Health Care Workforce shortages
throughout the state so um I think more
to come on that but yes it is it is a a
ongoing issue and we support they don't
come in front of this committee but we
support any and all efforts um of oplc
Office Professional Licensing and
certification that usually is an Edna um
um committee that they go in front of
but trying to streamline the licensing
process licensing is very important
licensing of clinicians not licensing of
Health Facilities but licensing of
clinicians because we need them to be
the public needs to be protected however
we need to make sure that that process
is as streamlined as possible accounts
receivable um I was not really prepared
to um address that but I appreciate you
raising the issue um yes our Hospital
are struggling with accounts receivable
and you are absolutely right you can't
you're not going to get a bill until um
the insurance company has processed the
claim because that would be
inappropriate because um we need to know
what the insurer is going to pay before
if if you in fact have any balance um if
it's a deductible co- Insurance co-pay
whatever it is and and it wouldn't be a
co-pay for inati but um so they have to
wait for it to process and that actually
you have identified another issue that
we're having with insurance companies
our accounts receivable we also do we do
a lot of surveys another survey we do um
and have been doing for about a year and
a half um has to do with our hospitals
accounts receivable again that's another
problem that is um like you said you're
you have identified a multitude of
problems that's why I think our system
is is in a bit of um crisis right now
because we are um struggling with having
accounts receivable anything over 90
days is considered a kind of a red flag
for a CFO we have a lot of accounts over
90 days and I think you're an an example
of one unfortunately that we did not get
re they the hospitals didn't get
reimbursed in in um timely manner and so
unfortunately um that delays getting
reimbursed and delays getting the bill
to you and it confuses the patient of
course they're like what is this I I was
there in March like you said so um that
is another issue that we're struggling
with and we do have a couple bills
actually that we're working on in the
Senate um to try to address some of that
that Pro problem okay thank you Miss
representative yes go ahead Leah
representative kosman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um so I've received a lot of
calls since um you know the roll out of
the covid vaccines and when New
Hampshire sure um hospitals started
mandating that um they've lost a lot of
Staff because of it and I know that
there's a lot of PE um prospective
nursing um students who have been trying
to do their clinicals at hospitals in
New Hampshire and um because it's
required they haven't been able to and
they can't complete their education
programs and we're we're put you know
we're putting a cork in the in the
Stream of potential new workers for this
shortage and I was was just wondering if
since the new information about the
Dismal e efficacy and by some measures
negative efficacy of the vaccines and
the injuries if the hospitalization
Hospital Association is doing any
surveys or taking another look at um
their approach to covid vaccination for
staff and if they um if you guys are
considering retracting that um
recommendation that all hospitals
require it because I think that that if
they loosen up some of those regulations
um it can help with bringing new people
into the workforce and bringing back
people who left um thank you for your
question um I our data that we have
collected from the hospitals um would be
um counter to some of the um data that
you have stated representative um we
have hospitals that have stated they did
not lose staff because of the
requirement which is actually a CMS
requirement and I think we've gone over
this um in this committee so I will not
the labor the point but um the hospitals
in order to be a CMS um certified
provider meaning Medicare and Medicaid
they must um mandate um that covid um
vaccines be um required at all hospitals
which they do and but there are
exceptions for medical and religious
exemptions which they um adhere to and
CMS reviews um so does the joint
commission and dnv which is another
accrediting agency to make sure that
they are um complying with the CMS
requirement that they in fact um have
this um um for all it's the safety of
the patients as well as the staff and
visitors so um I won't belabor that
point but um I our statistics actually
show um that we do not have um that
issue and that is not the issue that um
why folks um we have a staffing shortage
um there's a staffing shortage around um
the country and certainly within all of
healthc care and Beyond healthcare for
that matter so um and they do require
flu vaccines which they have for a long
time so um I I also have not heard that
um issue with the nurses um the nursing
um schools but our hospitals work very
closely with them so I can certainly
follow up all set uh representative Leon
has the last question um thank you thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
manahan for being here this is more of a
follow-up question and one where I'm
looking for just a short response of yes
no or off follow up with you um would
there be any interest if there are data
to show that our healthc care provider
pipeline has been restricted by the
vaccine mandate to support a waiver to
CMS for that if we do have data to show
that that's impacting our
Readiness I would need to better
understand that um I don't know how
exactly that would work this is a
national um HHS at the national level um
requires that this um this man this
mandate this re this um requirement so
I'll take that as a we'll follow up
afterwards sure happy too thank you okay
thank you Miss
Mahan um a little behind here but um
again we we appreciate everyone coming
um by state Primary Care Association are
they here I know there was a
presentation this morning that I may
have been um may have may have been um
the time we were going to hear from them
but we had also had them down for 1250
team State Commission on Aging yes hi
you hello my name is Rebecca sky and I'm
the executive director for the state
Commission on Aging thank you for having
me here today um um I promise to be
exceptionally brief um the commission
was created during the 2019 legislative
session primarily uh with a charge to
advise the governor and the state
legislature on issues related to aging
um I've on the top of the packet I've
handed out to you is the RSA that that
um you'll see in that uh in the RSA that
we are separate from any other state
agency part of the purpose of creating
us separate with to be able to bridge
the silos the various State agencies and
help them to uh work together uh better
on addressing the issues that affect all
of us as we age so um why was the
commission created if you turn to the
backside of the second piece there which
is the executive summary of our annual
annual report you'll see some um charts
and graphs which show you the
demographic um makeup of our state and
how it is aging um the commission is
here to help the governor and the legis
to um ensure that our policies systems
and communities are responsive to the uh
to these
changes the executive summary along with
the full report that you can find on our
web um Pages um reflects the study of
the issues the commission has engaged in
since its Inception uh they are just one
way that the commission seeks to fulfill
its charge you can see that um in this
report we've organized our
recommendations to the governor and to
all of you folks um
in three broad areas in this U report
that was published on November 1st of
this past year strengthening our
long-term services and support system of
care which I gather you've heard a lot
about earlier today grow our Direct Care
Workforce which I understand you've also
heard a lot about today and Advance our
age-friendly policy systems and
environments um this report is just one
way in which the commission fulfills its
charge um we are here for you as a
resource you can call upon us at any
time we will also be engaging with you
um on issues and providing testimony our
members as they come forward will be
wearing hopefully these uh Nifty little
blue badges that say the Commission on
Aging so to help you identify them um
and uh our commission is is made up of
of 26 appointed members um and they are
outlined in the RSA that uh um that you
have before you um and you can also see
a full list of exactly who those people
are if you turn to the third handout I
have for you which is the front page of
um our most recent edition of our
newsletter that we publish monthly um it
is put together by a commission member
she is amazing um this newsletter has
information not only on policies issues
but also has information that might be
helpful for you to um share with your
constituents on um to support them to as
they age in their
communities um it does go this
newsletter does go to your legislative
email address if you'd like it to go to
a different address please reach out to
us and we'll make sure it gets directly
to
you um what else did I want to cover um
commission is supported by myself I am a
full-time employee and another part-time
person uh that is the extent the breadth
and the width and we try to cover a lot
of territory there are many issues that
impact all of us as we age so um I've
also included today the last page of the
handouts that I gave you is our
strategic map um you can see what
motivates our investigation of issues um
we've really getting off the ground
getting our s established we spent a
great deal of time this past year
several years studying the issues that
come before you um we had our our
commission meets monthly and in addition
to that we also have four task force
that meet monthly in addition to our
policy team so top issues that we will
likely be address addressing with you
include um addressing and enhancing the
system of care for healthy aging there's
a Senate bill that would be coming
forward to address many of the issues
that were discussed previously um
long-term uh care issues related to
payment and quality but also of course
Workforce and professional lure um
prescription drugs tallah health and two
other issues that are top concerns
whenever older adults are surveyed is
housing and transportation likely not
coming before this committee but you you
will hear about um I'm sure these are
issues that you will be touched upon um
in other ways and that's all I have I'm
happy to answer any
questions yes representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair two-part question
what's your annual budget uh I'd like to
know how much of that's General funds
and which uh uh division of finance
reviews your the governor's portion of
your budget okay so um annual budget is
uh I have to double check but I believe
it's it's it's between 150 and
175,000 um I think it's at the 150 end
and uh it is General funds and we are
questions okay I guess we're all set
okay thank you very much thanks for
coming uh I know of no one else here toh
speak to us today is that
correct make sure my agenda hasn't been
changed on me or anything all right well
for the committee members again we uh we
had talked about getting together for
lunch across the street at Tandy so I
hope all of you can join us for that uh
coal they can actually take us a little
bit earlier so if people want to head
over there right afterwards that's
that'll work fine excellent
representative kofalt took the lead in
setting this up so thank you and again I
want to remind everyone we'll be meeting
next Wednesday to begin hearing bills at
9:00 a.m. and that'll be noticed of
course in the calendar so thank you very
SP